Hosting provided by Host Tornado. They offer website hosting packages, dedicated servers, and VPS solutions. HostT.net. Programming Throwdown, Episode 22, LaTeX. Take it away, Patrick. All right. So thank you for that introduction, Jason. Yes, yes.
本节目由 Host Tornado 提供。他们提供网站托管套餐、专用服务器和 VPS 解决方案。HostT.net。Programming Throwdown，第 22 期，LaTeX。Patrick，开始吧。好的。谢谢你的介绍，Jason。没错，没错。
You got the smooth radio voice going. Yeah, I want to, you know, keep myself all rounded. So I figured, you know. So I'll do some, you do some. Alright, I'll steal the thunder. Yeah, yeah. You guys missed the other three takes where Patrick did it. I just started screaming. No, you were crying
你这电台主持人的声音真顺滑。是啊，我想让自己全面发展。所以我想，嗯，我来一段，你来一段。好吧，我抢个风头。是啊，是啊。你们错过了 Patrick 录的其他三遍。我刚开始尖叫。不，你在哭。
because it was so beautiful. Oh yeah, that too. Yeah. Alright, anyways. So I'm behind the times, but I finally decided to upgrade my computer to a new version of Ubuntu. So I actually went to the long-term support one or whatever because I figured I don't really like this. I hate this.
因为太美了。哦，对，还有那个。是啊。好吧，总之。我有点跟不上时代了，但我终于决定把电脑升级到新版本的 Ubuntu。我实际上选了长期支持版之类的，因为我觉得我不喜欢这个。我讨厌这个。
So I'm just going to the LDS one. So I went to Precise Penguin. Yep, yep. Precise Penguin. Bad idea. Yeah. Do not, like, do not, like, wish I could just uninstall. So on my home computer, I've been on Precise Pengolin for,
所以我打算用 LDS 版。所以我选了 Precise Penguin。没错，没错。Precise Penguin。糟糕的主意。是啊。别，别，真希望我能直接卸载。所以在我家里的电脑上，我一直用着 Precise Pengolin，
well, I was on Precise Pengolin. I'm on 12.10 now. And that, there's a whole slew of issues there. But, yeah, you know, when I switched to Unity, I didn't mind it too much, you know? So I think this is the issue, right? So Unity, this is the new, I guess, UI kind of name thing. So it's replacing GNOME.
嗯，我之前用的是 Precise Pengolin。我现在用的是 12.10。那上面有一大堆问题。但是，是啊，你知道，当我切换到 Unity 时，我并不太介意，你知道吗？所以我认为这就是问题所在，对吧？所以 Unity，这是新的，我想是 UI 的名字之类的。所以它取代了 GNOME。
Okay. All right. So GNOME is what we had before. And yeah, now we have Unity. I wish we didn't. So the whole left bar thing, I don't like. You want to be united? I feel like they're just trying to be different just to do something different, right?
好的。好吧。所以 GNOME 是我们以前用的。是啊，现在我们有了 Unity。我真希望我们没有。所以左边那一栏，我不喜欢。你想团结一致吗？我觉得他们只是为了与众不同而与众不同，对吧？
Maybe I'm sure. I don't get into the whole. I'm not really involved in the community very much. I don't really know the backstory, so I'm probably offending a million people here. Yeah, everyone's so offended. That's okay. Yeah, I don't like it, personally. My personal preference is I hate it. So, like, I want my thing at the bottom back or at the top where I can click on each instance of like, if I have, you know, five, five Chrome
也许吧，我肯定。我没怎么参与整个社区。我不太了解背景故事，所以我可能冒犯了百万人。是啊，每个人都被冒犯了。没关系。是啊，我个人不喜欢它。我个人的偏好是我讨厌它。所以，我想把我的东西放回底部，或者放在顶部，在那里我可以点击每个实例，比如，如果我有，你知道，五个 Chrome
windows open or five, you know, command windows open, like whatever it is, like I want, I want to be able to like switch between them on the task. I don't, it doesn't work for me to not be able to like, I don't, I feel like it's constantly in my way instead of helping me. Yeah. So I, you know, I've had it for a while. At first I, I hated it. Now I've started to like it. There are some things that still drive me crazy. And one of them is they have the dash. They moved to this dashboard. So you actually have to click on dash home and then type in.
窗口打开，或者五个，你知道，命令窗口打开，不管是什么，我想，我想能够在任务栏上切换它们。我不，如果不能那样做，对我来说就没用，我不，我觉得它一直在阻碍我，而不是帮助我。是啊。所以，你知道，我用了一段时间了。起初我，我讨厌它。现在我开始喜欢它了。有些事情仍然让我抓狂。其中之一是他们有 Dash。他们改用了这个仪表盘。所以你实际上必须点击 Dash 主页，然后输入。
So if I want Chrome, I click on dash home, and then I have to type in Chrome and then it comes up. Whereas before, they had that bar at the top that had like applications, utilities. And it's like effectively like this multi-start menu thing going on. But you can push alt and get that too, right? You can do what? I think if you just tap alt, it comes up. Really?
所以如果我想要 Chrome，我点击 Dash 主页，然后我必须输入 Chrome，然后它就会出现。而之前，他们顶部有那个栏，上面有应用程序、实用工具之类的。它实际上就像是一个多重开始菜单。但你也可以按 Alt 键调出它，对吧？你说什么？我想如果你只是轻按 Alt 键，它就会出现。真的吗？
I think on my computer it does. Maybe that's a setting. I don't know. I feel like I did that on mine because every time I alt-tab and then I don't get the tab fast enough, that thing comes up. So maybe my setting is different. I don't know. Yeah, maybe.
我想在我的电脑上是这样的。也许那是个设置。我不知道。我觉得我在我的电脑上做过那个，因为每次我 Alt-Tab 切换，如果我没有足够快地切换标签，那个东西就会出来。所以也许我的设置不同。我不知道。是啊，也许吧。
Maybe that's something, too. Maybe I just haven't tweaked in the settings right. So I upgraded also a while ago to the new version of OSX. I don't even know what the names are. They're really bad. It was like Mountain Lion for a while. I don't know if it still is. Yes, that's it. Is that it? I don't know if it still is. Yes, that's it.
也许那也是个原因。也许我只是没把设置调好。所以我前段时间也升级到了新版本的 OSX。我甚至不知道它们的名字是什么。它们真的很糟糕。有一段时间叫 Mountain Lion。我不知道现在还是不是。是的，就是那个。是那个吗？我不知道现在还是不是。是的，就是那个。
Is that it? Okay. And they switched the switch. So I skipped two. I skipped one. So I skipped the intermediate. Okay. Maybe.
是那个吗？好的。他们切换了开关。所以我跳过了两个。我跳过了一个。所以我跳过了中间的那个。好的。也许吧。
I'm really bad with the names. This is horrible. I think I should have researched this. It doesn't matter. I went from scrolling normally on the trackpad to scrolling the reverse way. I tried it. I'm like, I'm going to like this.
我对名字真的很不擅长。这太糟糕了。我想我应该研究一下这个。没关系。我从在触控板上正常滚动变成了反向滚动。我试过了。我想，我会喜欢这个的。
This must be great. And then one day later, I turned it off.. I tried it, I'm like, I'm gonna like this, this must be great. And then one day later I turned it off. Yeah, me too. I'm like, nope, I don't like it. I don't think you lasted a lot longer than I did. I only lasted about an hour. I was like, I can't take it. And so it's like, it's funny, I still think about it.
这一定很棒。然后一天后，我把它关掉了。我试过了，我想，我会喜欢这个的，这一定很棒。然后一天后我把它关掉了。是啊，我也是。我想，不，我不喜欢它。我觉得你坚持的时间没比我长多少。我只坚持了一个小时。我当时想，我受不了了。所以这很有趣，我仍然在想它。
So let me just give everyone sort of a mental model for what's happening here. So it used to be that if you put two fingers on the pad and you moved your hand your fingers down you scroll down if you move them up you scroll up and it logically makes sense but if you think about it in terms of like putting your hand physically on a piece of paper no if the touchpad were the screen right exactly it was a piece of paper yeah and you touched it and slit it up the screen would move down like yes the paper would, where you're viewing would move lower on the page.
所以让我给大家一个关于这里发生了什么的心理模型。以前，如果你把两根手指放在触控板上，向下移动手指，你就会向下滚动；如果你向上移动，你就会向上滚动，这在逻辑上是有道理的。但如果你从物理上把手放在一张纸上的角度来考虑，不，如果触控板就是屏幕，对吧？完全正确，它是一张纸，是啊，你触摸它并向上滑动，屏幕就会向下移动，就像，是的，纸会，你正在看的地方会在页面上向下移动。
Like if you focus your eye on a spot and then you took your fingers, you put them down on a piece of paper and you moved up, that spot, what you're looking at on the page would be lower. So you would actually be scrolling down by moving your fingers up. It's basically like the tablet. That's what happens on the tablet. You touch on the screen and then the words underneath your finger stay underneath your finger exactly yeah which is why it makes sense yeah but on my trackpad because i've been doing it for i'm an old person i don't know what it is like oh people are like they're now they're making fun of us because uh they're
就像如果你把眼睛聚焦在一个点上，然后你把手指放在一张纸上，向上移动，那个点，你正在看页面的地方，就会变低。所以你实际上是通过向上移动手指来向下滚动。它基本上就像平板电脑。这就是平板电脑上发生的事情。你触摸屏幕，然后你手指下的文字就保持在你手指下面，完全正确，是啊，这就是为什么它有意义，是啊。但在我的触控板上，因为我已经这样做了，因为我是一个上了年纪的人，我不知道它是什么，就像，哦，人们现在在取笑我们，因为呃，他们
like oh those people are they're not old what are they talking about these crotchety old no they're like they're like those guys aren't old. Anyway, so, like, scroll. Anyways, yeah, I don't like that. So that was my rant, but the Ubuntu thing I really didn't like. And, I mean, there's all sorts of ways to get out from under it. The problem is, like, when you deviate from this, like, you're stuck in this thing. So there's always been, like, when before I was a big Windows user, and I still do use Windows for a lot of stuff, you know,
就像，哦，那些人，他们不老，他们在说什么，这些脾气暴躁的老人，不，他们就像，那些家伙不老。总之，所以，滚动。总之，是啊，我不喜欢那样。所以那是我的抱怨，但我真的不喜欢 Ubuntu 的那个东西。而且，我的意思是，有很多方法可以摆脱它。问题是，当你偏离这个时，就像，你被困在这个东西里了。所以一直以来，就像，在我成为 Windows 大用户之前，而且我仍然在很多事情上使用 Windows，你知道，
there's, like, all these shell hack things you can do to, like, make your computer look different. And that's cool, but then if you go to upgrade the next one, it doesn't work and you're used to something different. So I feel like I want to stay as close to vanilla default installation as possible, because then I don't always have to reinstall stuff and change stuff.
有，就像，所有这些你可以做的 shell 破解，让你的电脑看起来不同。这很酷，但如果你去升级下一个版本，它就不能用了，而你已经习惯了不同的东西。所以我感觉我想尽可能保持原生的默认安装，因为这样我就不必总是重新安装东西和更改东西。
I used to do this. I used to even, when I ran Windows, I used to have all of these things. I had one which split my desktop into four if I wanted it to. I had another one where the terminal, it was easier to paste. If you just right-clicked, it pasted instead of having to do something else. I don't know.
我以前这样做过。我甚至，当我运行 Windows 时，我曾经有所有这些东西。我有一个可以将我的桌面分成四个，如果我想的话。我有另一个，终端，粘贴更容易。如果你只是右键点击，它就会粘贴，而不必做其他事情。我不知道。
But I made all these tweaks to it, and then I updated to, I think it went from XP to 7, and I lost everything, and I just said, forget it. I'm not going to waste time. And then the same tools don't work anymore, and you can't do that. Or if you go use somebody else's computer, doesn't work the same yeah yeah i have a friend who's addicted well he's like a real a zealot for devorah keyboards and like he came over to my house and couldn't even like type an email it was hilarious so i mean same thing they've always thought like oh i should do this right like it makes the way the qwerty keyboard is set up is
但我对它做了所有这些调整，然后我更新到，我想是从 XP 到 7，我失去了一切，我只是说，算了吧。我不会浪费时间。然后同样的工具不再起作用了，你不能那样做。或者如果你去用别人的电脑，它工作得不一样，是啊，是啊，我有一个朋友，他沉迷于，嗯，他就像一个 Dvorak 键盘的狂热分子，他来到我家，甚至不能像打一封电子邮件，这太搞笑了。所以我的意思是同样的事情，他们一直认为，哦，我应该这样做，对吧，它让 QWERTY 键盘的设置方式
retarded like it's literally meant to make you type slower. Yep. And that's why they invented it. And we've probably all heard this story, right? So, like, I want to switch, but the problem is, like, I know if I switch, not every computer, like, I don't have complete control over every computer that I use or I go to somebody else's computer or somebody, you know, like, especially, like, at work.
很弱智，就像它字面上就是为了让你打字更慢。没错。这就是他们发明它的原因。我们可能都听过这个故事，对吧？所以，我想切换，但问题是，我知道如果我切换，不是每台电脑，就像，我没有完全控制我使用的每一台电脑，或者我去别人的电脑，或者某人，你知道，就像，特别是在工作中。
Somebody, like, it's rare, but somebody sometimes needs to use, like, show me something on the computer or type something in. They can't use it. Yep. Like, you know, if I reboot or something updates like auto updates and like somehow removes it and I boot up and like my password won't work like it's gonna take me forever to figure it out like yeah then you're typing things that don't match a keyboard yeah I just I don't know it it
某人，就像，这很少见，但某人有时需要使用，就像，在电脑上给我看点什么，或者输入点什么。他们用不了。没错。就像，你知道，如果我重启或者某些东西更新，比如自动更新，然后不知何故删除了它，我启动后，我的密码无法工作，就像，我需要永远才能弄清楚它，是啊，然后你输入的字符与键盘不匹配，是啊，我只是，我不知道，它
should be good and I should do it I guess I just but it's not worth it that's the same thing with a lot of a lot of tech not just software but even other stuff i remember like having early versions of ipads right like essentially these other tablet devices or you know palm pilot style things and it's never worked they didn't have wide adoption you were kind of out on the fringes and they just didn't have the same support once something goes mainstream we don't like it because now it's not elitist and cool at some level, but at another level, it's just so much
应该很好，我应该这样做，我想，但我只是觉得不值得。这和很多很多科技产品一样，不仅仅是软件，甚至其他东西。我记得像拥有早期版本的 iPad，对吧，本质上是这些其他平板设备，或者你知道，Palm Pilot 风格的东西，它从来没用过，它们没有被广泛采用，你有点处于边缘地带，一旦某样东西成为主流，它们就没有同样的支持了，我们不喜欢它，因为现在它不再是精英和酷了，在某种程度上，但在另一个层面上，它只是好多了，
nicer because now I can go to Target or Walmart or wherever, Amazon, and I find like a hundred different choices for what phone case I want if I have a current popular phone or an iPad or whatever. Because stuff is more mainstream. Yeah, I mean, I have an Android phone and I still
因为现在我可以去 Target 或 Walmart，或者任何地方，亚马逊，如果我有当前流行的手机或 iPad 或其他什么，我可以找到一百种不同的手机壳选择。因为东西更主流了。是啊，我的意思是，我有一部 Android 手机，我仍然
suffer from this a little bit. And not so much anymore because Android phones are getting more popular. But especially like a year ago, it was like I want this cool case, but it's only for iPhone. Well, so, yeah, so I have an iPhone. This is what my main phone is. And, like, it works really well. So I had an Android phone. And the nice thing is that they've gotten less split.
为此受点苦。现在没那么多了，因为 Android 手机越来越受欢迎了。但特别是一年前，就像我想要这个酷炫的手机壳，但它只适用于 iPhone。好吧，所以，是啊，所以我有一部 iPhone。这是我的主力手机。而且，它工作得非常好。所以我有一部 Android 手机。好的一点是它们变得没那么分裂了。
So it used to be, like, everybody had a slightly different version of the same Android phone yeah right you know it's very fragment now they're going like less so like one phone will be released across all the carriers yeah and so that's nicer because then you can make a case but if you have like oh one has a keyboard and one doesn't and one has a little antenna and one doesn't like then yeah that never happens yeah yeah it's a nightmare anyways yeah don't don't like the unity thing I I'm sorry. Not a fan. We'll see. I want to know your opinion in like three or four months. So I've been at it for like two or three weeks now.
所以过去，就像，每个人都有同一部 Android 手机的略微不同的版本，是啊，对吧，你知道，它现在非常碎片化，他们变得没那么碎片化了，就像一部手机会在所有运营商中发布，是啊，所以这更好，因为那样你就可以制作一个手机壳，但如果你有，比如，哦，一个有键盘，一个没有，一个有小天线，一个没有，就像，那永远不会发生，是啊，是啊，这简直是噩梦，总之，是啊，不喜欢那个 Unity 的东西，我，我很抱歉。不是粉丝。我们走着瞧。我想在三四个月后知道你的意见。所以我已经用了两三周了。
Yeah. And I gave it a fair shake. I'm really tempted to turn it off. I want to figure out the best way to turn it off. But you know what? Or install something else. Especially with Linux or any of these OSs, you know what's going to happen. The next version, like whatever hack you're doing to get around it now will be gone.
是啊。而且我公平地尝试了。我真的很想把它关掉。我想找出关掉它的最好方法。但你知道吗？或者安装其他东西。特别是对于 Linux 或任何这些操作系统，你知道会发生什么。下一个版本，就像你现在为了绕过它所做的任何破解都会消失。
Yes. Like it won't even be there. That's my rant. Yeah. Okay. So now onto something slightly happier. I'll take the first news story. Now something slightly happier.
是的。就像它甚至不会在那里。这就是我的抱怨。是啊。好的。现在进入稍微快乐一点的事情。我来讲第一个新闻故事。现在稍微快乐一点的事情。
A lot of people are killing each other virtually. So Call of Duty Black Ops 2. So I'm not a huge like current gamer. I like video games, but I play a lot of old video games. Same here. Cheap. Sorry, I wait for them to, like, crash in price,
很多人在虚拟世界中互相残杀。所以《使命召唤：黑色行动 2》。所以我不是一个巨大的，像当前的玩家。我喜欢电子游戏，但我玩很多老电子游戏。我也是。便宜。抱歉，我等它们，就像，价格暴跌，
and it would be, like, really cheap Steam sale. Oh, yeah, I'm thinking really old. Oh, or let's not, like, I love playing my Super Nintendo games or my NES games or, like, I like old stuff. No, no, it's just simpler, and I don't have a lot of time to play video games, or I don't make a lot of time to play video games, I should say. But it has 150 million hours of in-play.
然后它会，就像，非常便宜的 Steam 特卖。哦，是啊，我想到的是非常老的。哦，或者我们不要，就像，我喜欢玩我的超级任天堂游戏或我的 NES 游戏，或者，就像，我喜欢老东西。不，不，它只是更简单，我没有太多时间玩电子游戏，或者我应该说，我没有抽出太多时间玩电子游戏。但它有 1.5 亿小时的游玩时间。
That's crazy. It's absolutely insane. A billion dollars? A billion dollars in 15 days. Faster than Avatar hit a billion dollars. So the new media consumption is so interesting. It's so expensive. Personally, I feel like...
这太疯狂了。这绝对是疯狂的。十亿美元？15 天内十亿美元。比《阿凡达》达到十亿美元的速度还快。所以新的媒体消费太有趣了。它太贵了。个人而言，我觉得……
Like $60 or something? I don't know how much. I would say probably $70, right? It can be really expensive, and I don't know. I mean, we should look at it. It's like $60 or something I don't know how much that's why I would say probably $70 right like it can be really expensive and I don't know I mean we should look at it it's probably $50 or $60 but still like
像 60 美元左右？我不知道多少钱。我会说大概 70 美元，对吧？它可能非常贵，我不知道。我的意思是，我们应该看看。它大概是 60 美元左右，我不知道多少钱，这就是为什么我会说大概 70 美元，对吧，它可能非常贵，我不知道。我的意思是，我们应该看看，它可能是 50 或 60 美元，但仍然，就像
it's just crazy to me like that's a lot of and I'm not saying like if you're going to play it for a lot of hours like well worth it oh no it's totally worth it
这对我来说太疯狂了，就像那是很多，我不是说，如果你要玩很多小时，就像，非常值得，哦不，它完全值得
like the dollar per hour thing but I'm just like hitting a billion dollars is crazy like people have talked about this a lot like oh are video games eating into the movie market
就像每小时美元的东西，但我只是觉得达到十亿美元太疯狂了，人们已经谈论过很多次了，就像，哦，电子游戏是在蚕食电影市场吗
or vice versa and video games are becoming more like movies and like back and forth and all this stuff. And I feel like they're two very different styles of entertainment for me personally. I don't replace one with the other. I feel like they're just different. But, yeah, I mean, it's a serious business being in this now. The thing that blows me away, so movies, right? So you could watch, watch you know some people watch
还是反之亦然，电子游戏正变得越来越像电影，来来回回，所有这些东西。我觉得对我个人来说，它们是两种非常不同的娱乐风格。我不会用一个代替另一个。我觉得它们只是不同。但是，是啊，我的意思是，现在从事这个行业是一项严肃的生意。让我感到震惊的是，电影，对吧？所以你可以看，看，你知道有些人看
let's say rocky horror picture show right that's that's like a cult classic some people watch that show like every month like they'll go and watch rocky horror and it's like a big event people have fun so so it's it's not true that you only watch a movie once that part isn't true but if you look at like overall most people only watch a movie once, like a particular movie. With a video game, the hours that you put into it vary wildly. Like some people might play Call of Duty or any game for a couple hours and they're done. And some people play it for like months and months and months, right? And so this whole like dynamic of sort of like just having this extremely variable mileage
比如《洛基恐怖秀》，对吧，那就像一部邪典经典，有些人每个月都看那部电影，就像他们会去看《洛基恐怖秀》，这就像一个大事件，人们玩得很开心，所以，所以说你只看一次电影是不对的，那部分是不对的，但如果你看，就像，总体而言，大多数人只看一次电影，就像某部特定的电影。对于电子游戏，你投入的时间差异很大。就像有些人可能玩《使命召唤》或任何游戏几个小时，然后就结束了。而有些人玩了几个月又几个月，对吧？所以这种，就像，从这种娱乐中获得极度可变的里程的整个动态，我觉得太迷人了，然后你还有这个东西，有些游戏，就像，你知道，有巨大的预算，比如《使命召唤》，我敢肯定他们的预算在几千万，对吧，是啊，但有些游戏只是，就像，就像《超级食肉男孩》，你玩过这个游戏吗？不，它是一个平台游戏，你必须，就像，跑和跳，呃，就像有一些小东西试图研磨，就像你是一团肉，你在一个像肉类加工厂的地方，你必须穿过所有的刀片而不被切到，或者其他什么，呃，所以，它是一个人做的，或者两个人利用业余时间做的，或者我猜也许是他们的全职工作，但这两个人做了
that you get out of this entertainment i think is just fascinating and then you have this other thing too where some games are like you know have this massive budget like call of duty i'm sure their budget was in the tens of millions right yeah but then some games are just like like like super meat boy have you played this game no it's a platformer where you have to like run and jump and uh like there's a little like things trying to grind like you're a blob of meat and you're in this like meat processing facility and you have to go through all the blades without getting cut or whatever and uh so and it's like one guy made it or two guys made it in their spare time or i guess maybe it was their full-time job but these two guys made
它，它为我提供了数百小时的娱乐，就像试图，就像在这些迷宫中导航，所有这些东西，仅仅是这个，就像投资与娱乐的比例，投资与回报，然后回报与娱乐，这些动态简直令人难以置信，而且这是，就像，现在很难探索，或者很难量化，是啊，而且享受，随着时间的推移会改变，对吧，所以如果你去玩，特别是像这个《黑色行动 2》，第一天人们可能就在线开始玩了，并且变得很厉害，是啊，然后，就像你几周后加入，不管怎样，不，让我们看看，然后你
it and it provided me like hundreds of hours of entertainment like trying to like navigate these mazes and all this stuff and just the fact that like this ratio of like investment to entertain investment to return and then return to entertainment like these dynamics are just incredible and it's something that like is very hard to explore right now or very hard to know quantify yeah and the enjoyment like over time changes right so like if you go play especially like this black ops 2 like day one people probably got online started playing right away and got good yeah and then like you jump on like a couple weeks later whatever like no let's see and then you're
就像，不，就像它很糟糕，即使有匹配系统和所有这些东西，是啊，好吧，我的意思是，你可以缓解其中的一些，但仍然，就像，我的意思是，你并不总是拥有最好的。你必须坚持下去，直到它变得真正令人愉快，对吧？就像，在你至少做得足够好，以至于它有点有趣之前。我的意思是，也许在那之前它也很有趣，对某些人来说。我猜这取决于。你知道，在 Xbox 上，他们实际上有模式。他们有一个硬核玩家模式。
like no like it's bad even with matchmaking and all that stuff like yeah okay i mean you can alleviate some of that but still like i mean, you don't always have the best. You have to stick with it before it becomes really enjoyable, right? Like, before you're at least doing well enough where it's kind of fun. I mean, maybe it's fun before that, too, for some people. I guess it depends. You know, with the Xbox, they actually have modes. They have a hardcore gamer mode.
然后他们有另一个模式，我不记得了。但第三个，也就是我选的那个，是家庭模式。这并不意味着你看不到血腥之类的东西。它只是意味着，就像……你可以玩完整个游戏而不死。哦，是啊，是啊。它就像，基本上，它就像，嗯，它是为了多人游戏，但它就像，你有一个家庭，你不可能打败
Then they have another mode, which I can't remember. But then the third one, which is what I picked, was family mode. And it doesn't mean you don't see blood or anything like that. It just means, like... You can get through the whole game without dying. Oh, yeah, yeah. It's like, basically, it's like, well, it's for multiplayer, but it's like, you have a family, you're not going to be able to beat
这个整天练习的孩子。所以，就像，你在这个联盟里和你自己一起玩，和其余那些玩得不好的人一起。是啊。就像在机场，他们有这个，他们有不同的通道，比如商务通道，普通通道，家庭通道，我总是看到人们走错通道，就像，这有什么目的，就像带着 30 个包的家庭，走在那个显示商务旅客经常旅行的通道，
this kid who, like, practices all day. So, like, you play in this league on your own with the rest of the people who can't play well. Yeah. It's like at the airport they have this they have like different lanes like the business lane the normal lane the family lane i always see people going in the wrong lane it's like what is the purpose of this is like the family with like 30 bags like going in the one that shows like business traveler travels all the
有一个随身行李，或者其他什么，你知道，你，总之，好的。所以价格是零售价 60 美元，主机和电脑，但看起来你可以以比这更便宜的价格买到它。所以这就是让我感到震惊的事情，对吧，是我买了，这会让我听起来真的很可悲，但我买了《超级马里奥 3》，就在它刚出来的时候。实际上，公平地说，我妈妈在我刚出来的时候给我买了《超级马里奥 3》，我想是 70 美元，现在已经超过 20 年了，电子游戏仍然卖 70 美元
time has one carry-on or whatever you know you anyways, okay. So the price is retail $60 for the console and the computer, but it looks like you can get it for cheaper than that. So this is the thing that blows my mind, right, is I bought, and this is going to make me sound really pathetic, but I bought Super Mario 3 right when it came out. Actually, to be fair, my mom bought Super Mario 3 for me right when it came out, and it was i think 70 dollars and now it has been over 20 years and video games are still selling for 70 dollars
嗯，我从来没想过那个，是啊，就像电子游戏的价格在二十年里没有变过，而且内容量和预算都大幅增加了。我敢肯定《SMB3》，《超级马里奥兄弟 3》的预算，即使算上通货膨胀，也不是《使命召唤》的预算，对吧？所以仅仅是那部分就很疯狂。利润率已经大幅下降了，对吧，在电子游戏上。是啊，但他们卖得更多了。是啊，那也是真的。我很确定 1.5 亿小时没有被玩
well i never thought about that yeah like the price of a video game hasn't changed in two decades and like just the amount of content and the budget has gone up dramatically. I'm sure the budget for SMB3, Super Mario Bros. 3, was not what the budget of Call of Duty is, even with inflation, right? So it's just that part is wild. The margins have come way down, right, on video games. Yeah, but they're selling a lot more. Yeah, that's true too. I'm pretty sure 150 million hours weren't played
在《超级马里奥兄弟 3》的前两周，是啊，完全，嗯，是啊，我没看到初始价格，你可能是对的，我的意思是，我记得看到一些关于主机非常昂贵的东西，就像我们抱怨它们现在很贵，但就像它们过去非常昂贵，特别是如果你考虑到通货膨胀，嗯，所以，是啊。好的。我们的下一个新闻故事。你找到了一个你想要作为圣诞礼物的东西。嗯，等等。我也在 Answers.Yahoo 上找到了。
in the first two weeks of super mario brothers three yeah totally um yeah i don't see the initial price you're probably right i mean i remember seeing something about consoles being really expensive like we complain about them being expensive now but like that they used to be crazy expensive especially if you take into account inflation um So, yeah. All right. Our next news story. You found something that you want for Christmas. Well, hang on. I also found on Answers.Yahoo.
《超级马里奥兄弟 3》刚出来时花了多少钱？这家伙说 50 美元。哦，不，但另一个人说 70 美元。是啊。好的。所以，大概 50 美元。是啊，所以价格差不多。是啊，是啊。好的，抱歉。
How much did Super Mario Bros. 3 cost when it first came out? This guy said $50. Oh, no, but somebody else said $70. Yeah. Okay. So, around $50. Yeah, so about the same price. Yeah, yeah. Okay, sorry.
好的。总之。毁了那个过渡。是啊。所以，是啊，所以我完全，你知道，实际上我妈妈今天说，我不知道圣诞节给你买什么。你知道，她每年都这么说。好吧，现在你知道她要花 70 美元了。
All right. Anyway. Ruined that transition. Yeah. So, yeah, so I totally, you know, actually my mom today was like, I don't know what to get you for Christmas. You know, she always says this every year. Well, now you know she's going to spend $70.
根据通货膨胀调整。是啊，完全正确。所以我想要一个《超级马里奥 3》卡带，呃，所以我实际上认为这个东西非常酷，我只是在录制节目之前几分钟才发现它，但我立刻想要研究，经过大量的研究，他们有一个 Android 棒式电脑，这个想法是它有 HDMI，所以你可以把它插到你的电视上。这个我链接到的……它看起来像一个拇指驱动器。
Adjusted for inflation. Yeah, exactly. So I want a Super Mario 3 cartridge uh so i actually think this thing is totally cool i only found out about it minutes before before um recording the show but i immediately want research after lots of research um they have an android stick pc and the idea is it has the hdmi, so you can plug it into your television. This one that I linked to... And it looks like a thumb drive.
是啊，没错。它非常小。这个我链接到的显然需要，就像，某种可以通过 HDMI 线提供电源的电视。现在，那个，我的意思是，它看起来上面有一个端口，就像，一个 USB 电源之类的。是啊，所以你可以……如果你的电视支持从 HDMI 获取电源，那就可以工作，
Yeah, that's right. It's very small. This one I linked to apparently needs, like, certain type of TV that can provide power through the HDMI cable. Now, that one, I mean, it looks like it has a port there for, like, a USB power everything. Yeah, so you can either... If your TV support's getting power from HDMI, that'll work,
较新的电视确实支持，但也有其他方式为它供电。哦，完美。是啊，所以想象一下，你拥有在手机或类似设备中拥有的那种 Android 性能，但它可以连接到你的电视，而不需要迷你 HDMI。它只有完整的 HDMI。你可以让它 24/7 连接到你的电视，
which the newer TVs do, but there's a way to power it alternatively as well. Oh, perfect. Yeah, so imagine you have the kind of Android power that you would in a phone or something, but it can connect to your TV without having a mini HDMI. It just has complete HDMI. And you can have it hook up to your TV 24-7,
你可以用它做各种酷炫的事情。所以我认为这是一个非常有趣的玩具。我认为有很多酷炫的事情我想用它做，是啊，它有点像树莓派风格的东西，对吧，是啊，是啊，你可以插入，呃，或者你可以使用无线键盘和鼠标，所以我假设它有一种蓝牙接收器或发射器，呃，所以，是啊，它看起来很有趣，我还没真的，你知道，我刚发现它，所以我还没想过，脑海中立刻浮现的想法是让 MAME 在上面运行，然后拥有，就像，一个……
and you do all sorts of cool stuff with it. So I think it's a really fun toy. I think that there's a lot of cool stuff i'd want to do with it yeah it's kind of like the raspberry pi style thing right yeah yeah they you can plug in uh or you can use a wireless keyboard and mouse so i'm assuming it has a kind of bluetooth receiver or transmitter um so yeah it seems pretty fun i i haven't really you know i just found out about it so i haven't thought about what immediately thought that comes to mind is to get MAME running on it and then have, like, a...
所以，为了玩街机游戏？是啊，是啊，拥有，就像，有史以来最小的街机柜。实际上，我想涉足，就像，木工。就像，不是认真的，就像，看起来很好的那种，但只是，就像，一把锯子和一块木头，能够制作东西，因为，就像，我真的很笨拙。我们得找时间再谈谈这个。我实际上开始做木工了，但，就像，看起来很好的那种。哦，哇。我们下期节目再做。那将是我们的下期节目。COLTON OGDEN：“我们得找时间再谈谈这个。我实际上开始做木工了，但看起来很好的那种。” DAVID EASTMAN：“哦，哇。”
So, to play arcade games? Yeah, yeah, have, like, the smallest arcade cabinet ever. Actually, I want to get into, like, woodworking. Like, not serious, like, where it looks good, but just, like, a saw and a piece of wood and have, like, be able to make stuff, because, like, I'm really inept. We'll have to talk about this another time. I actually started doing woodworking, but, like, the kind where it looks good. Oh, wow. We'll do that next show. That'll be our next show. COLTON OGDEN:" We'll have to talk about this another time. I actually started doing woodworking, but the kind where it looks good. DAVID EASTMAN:" Oh, wow.
我们下期节目再做。那将是我们的下期节目。我们得记住。所以我想制作——” COLTON OGDEN：“嗯，我应该说那种看起来试图让它看起来很好的那种。抱歉。” DAVID EASTMAN：“目标是好的。”
We'll do that next show. That'll be our next show. We'll have to remember. So I want to make--" COLTON OGDEN:" Well, I should say the kind that looked like attempting to try to make it look good. Sorry. DAVID EASTMAN:" The goal is good.
用我的，目标只是平庸。是啊，它是功能性的。看，我想用这些小棍子之一制作一个街机柜，还有一个非常小的，或者也许是一个能放进你口袋的街机柜。COL 就像，我不知道，就像一个非常小的，或者也许像一个街机。我想有人做过那个。我看到了。在那些，就像，黑客，就像电脑黑客的东西之一上。是啊。
With mine, the goal is just mediocre. Yeah, it's functional. See, I want to make an arcade cabinet with one of these little sticks and a really tiny, or maybe an arcade cabinet that fits in your pocket. COL like, I don't know, like a really tiny or maybe like an arcade. I think somebody did that. I saw that. On one of the like hacker, like computer hacker things. Yeah.
就像超级微型街机柜之类的。它非常小。哦，那很酷。是啊。谁知道我会做什么？也许它会是一个套件，然后你就不必做任何木工了。哦，完美。你的木工可以只是把它粘起来，然后你甚至不必担心。
Like super miniature arcade cabinet or something. It was like really small. Oh, that's cool. Yeah. Who knows what I'm going to do? Maybe it'll be a kit and then you don't have to do any woodworking. Oh, perfect. Your woodworking can just be to glue it up and then you don't even have to worry about.
所以这个看起来像是装你的手机的。哦，那太棒了。但你可以做，我的意思是，你可以破解它，让它成为别的东西，把它粘起来，然后你甚至不必担心它。所以这个看起来像是装你的手机的。哦，那太棒了。但你可以破解它，让它成为别的东西。好的，总之，我们正在看图片，你们看不到它们。太棒了。有史以来最好的播客。说到木工。
So this one looks like it houses your phone. Oh, that's awesome. But you could do like, I mean, you could hack it to just be something glue it up and then you don't even have to worry about it. So this one looks like it houses your phone. Oh, that's awesome. But you could hack it to just be something else. Okay, anyways, we're looking at pictures and you guys cannot see them. Awesome. Best podcast ever. Speaking of woodworking.
所以，是啊。所以关于我做木工的疯狂想法，所以我的木工目标之一是建造自动机。真的吗？所以自动机是那些，呃，嗯，它们意味着各种各样的事情，但我想到的是木制装置，你在侧面有一个小手柄，你转动它，然后有一个场景发生，就像，几乎像一个立体模型，如果你知道那是什么，在小盒子的顶部，所以你就像转动它，然后有，就像，你知道，就像一匹马假装它在跑，或者像一只毛毛虫假装它在跑，或者像一只毛毛虫假装它在爬。或者某个家伙，就像，假装他在吃三明治和挥手，或者一只跳过去的狗。
So, yeah. So on my notion of crazy things to do with woodworking, so one of my goals with woodworking is to build automata. Really? So automata are those, uh well they means a variety of things but the ones i'm thinking over wooden contraptions where you have like a little hand crank on the side and you crank it and there's like a scene that takes place like almost like a diorama if you know what that is on top of the little box so you like crank it and there's like you know like a horse that pretends like it's running or like a caterpillar pretends like it's running or like a caterpillar pretends like it's crawling. Or some guy that's like pretending like he's eating a sandwich and waving or a dog that jumps through.
我看到了一些完全史诗般的东西。那和你说的方向一致。这家伙做了一辆自行车。作为踩自行车的一部分，一套机械，就像一套机械执行器之类的东西动了。而且它是完全模拟的。所以它不是电脑之类的，呃，它，一支笔画出了他的签名，或者像非常接近他的签名的东西，是啊，是啊，是啊
I saw something that's totally epic. That's along the lines of what you're talking about. This guy made a bicycle. And as part of pedaling the bicycle, a mechanical, like a set of mechanical actuators and stuff went. And it's totally analog. So it's not computer or anything um it a Pen drew his signature or like something pretty close to his signature Yeah, yeah, yeah
是啊，所以这会有，就像，齿轮和，是啊，滑轮和螺丝，而且，是啊，所有这些疯狂的东西让上面的东西做点什么，你把底部留着，所有那些东西都暴露在外，所以人们可以有点看到它作为怀旧的一部分，怀旧的一部分，是啊，对，这就是我有点想做的，那太神奇了，呃，但这是一个非常崇高的目标，我不知道我什么时候会做，所以我想做的另一件事是做一个木钟，所以你可以制作，就像，所有的齿轮和钟摆和擒纵机构，所有让它滴答作响的东西，而且都是木制的，好的，所以我有一些疯狂宏大的想法，哦，那太神奇了，所以，所以你有木工，就像，我的意思是，你有某种工作台吗？我，我，呃，正在获取它。所以，就像，我正在
Yeah So like so this would have like gears and yeah pulleys and screws And yeah all these crazy things to make the things on top do something and you leave the bottom where all those things are exposed So people can kind of see it working as part of the nostalgia of the nostalgia of it yeah right that's what i kind of want to do that's amazing uh it but it's a very lofty goal i don't know when i'll make so the other thing i want to do is make a wooden clock so you can make like all the gears and the pendulum and the escapement everything that makes it tick and it's all out of wood all right so i have crazy grandiose ideas oh that's amazing so so do you have a woodworking like i mean do you have some kind of benches? I'm like, I'm like, uh, acquiring it. So like, I'm like in the
过程中，就像开始，就像做一些小项目，学习技能，那种东西，努力提升自己。那太棒了。所以我看到了这个，它立刻引起了我的兴趣，因为当我长大的时候，我总是班里那个，就像，当有人问我时，我会说，为什么？但就像，不是为了像个混蛋，而是像我想知道，就像，为什么是那样，所以，就像，其中一件事是电脑，就像，哦，它用二进制计数，就像，很长一段时间我以为，就像，哦，二进制不能代表每一个数字，因为，就像，有人只是告诉他，我，就像，那太疯狂了，就像只有一和零，就像，真的，是啊，没人费心，就像，没人，我的老师，
process of like starting, like doing some small projects, learning the skills, that kind of stuff, working my way up. That's great. So I saw this and it immediately intrigued me because when I was growing up, I would always be the kid in the class who like, when somebody asked me, I'd be like, why? But like, not just to be like a jerk but like I wanted to know like why is it that way and so like one of the things was computers like oh it counts in binary it's like for the longest time I thought like Oh binary couldn't represent every number because like somebody just told him I like that's crazy like ones and zeros only like seriously yeah nobody bothered like nobody my teachers the
当时不知道如何真正向我解释，就像，不，这是，它是一个数字系统，这就是为什么它可以代表每一个数字，二，没人，不，不，没有那个，对吧，它就像，呃，完全更晦涩，而其中一件事，一旦我弄清楚了，我就像在这次探索中，就像我想了解电脑是如何处理事情的，因为人们知道这个，对吧，就像，哦，对电脑了解一点的人会说，就像，哦，它有一个指令集，你会说，什么，什么是指令集，它做什么，它怎么，就像，它怎么知道数字，知道另一个数字，把数字放在一起，你知道，然后做点什么，对吧，就像，它是怎么工作的，所以这个叫 Digicomp 2 的套件，是啊，嗯，是一个 50 年代制造的东西，它是什么，我只是要试着描述它。它就像一块平坦的木头，在一个角度上。
time didn't know how to really explain that to me that like no this is it's a number system here's why it can represent every number two nobody no no none of that right it's like um completely more obscure and one of the things once i figured that i was like on this quest like i want to understand how a computer processes things because people know this right like oh people who know a little bit about computers would say like oh it has an instruction set you'd be like what what's an instruction set what does it do how does it like how does it know the number know the other number put the numbers together you know and make something right like how does that work and so this kit called the digicomp 2 yeah um is a something that was made in the 50s and what it is is i'm just going to try to describe it. It's like a wooden flat piece of wood that's on an angle.
它有，看起来像那些迷宫东西之一，弹珠在里面流动，或者其他什么。而且有小拨动，木制拨动件。那些都是拨动。而且它有小滚珠轴承。我想它们实际上是弹珠机球。所以小滚珠轴承流过这些木制通道，沿着这个倾斜的板。然后有小拨动，你左右切换，它们就像本质上是
And it has like, looks like one of those labyrinth things where the marbles kind of like flow through or whatever. And there's little toggle, wooden toggle pieces. Those are all toggle. And it has the little ball bearings. I think they're actually pachinko balls. So little ball bearings that flow through these wooden channels down this slanted board. And then there's little toggles you switch left and right that are like essentially the
指令集，你可以有点像放入位置的位。当东西流过时，你可以做一些事情，比如创建一个加法器，或者创建一个，你知道，也许甚至是一个乘法器。它有，就像，整个指令集，你可以做。我没有完全读完所有东西，因为我当时想，哦，我会想要其中一个，而且这会是一件可怕的事情。所以 50 年代制造的旧的，就像这个塑料东西，而且有点便宜。
instruction set, the bits that you can kind of like put into positions. And as stuff flows through, you can do things like create an adder or create a, you know, maybe even a multiplier. It has like a whole instruction set that you can do. I didn't fully kind of read through everything because I was like, oh, I'm going to want one of these and it's going to be a terrible thing. So the old one made in the 50s was like this plastic thing and it was kind of cheap.
人们用这个来学习，就像二进制是如何工作的，以及如何，就像设置指令并让它运行。而这些人用木头制造了它，为了，就像，为了新一代的人。所以它相当昂贵。它就像几百美元。但他们说他们试图，就像，做这个，为了能够用，就像，坚固的塑料制造另一个，并有点教育人们。
And people use this to learn like how did the binary work and how to like set the instructions and make it go. And these people created it out of wood to kind of like for a new generation of people. So it's fairly expensive. It was like a couple hundred dollars. But they said they were trying to like do this to be able to make another one out of like a sturdy plastic and kind of educate people.
而且它对我来说极其迷人，就像在不是，你知道，电的东西里做通用计算。是啊，那太神奇了。所以它完全是在，就像，现实世界中。没有，它不插墙。没有电池。是啊，你们绝对应该，你知道，我们有每篇文章的链接。这就像一个高度视觉化的，你们绝对应该点击链接并看看这个。
And it was like supremely fascinating to me that like doing general purpose computation in something that isn't, you know, electrical. Yeah, that's amazing. So it's all completely in like the real world. There's no, it doesn't plug into the wall. There's no batteries. Yeah, you guys should definitely, you know, we have links for every article. This is like a highly visual, you should definitely click on the link and check this out.
因为这真的很令人印象深刻。我不知道他们是否有 YouTube 视频。不，那会很酷。所以，我的意思是，我只是有点像有这个，就像东西，就像教学。所以我现在有一个女儿，她才一岁，但我有，就像这个宏大的愿景，就像教她在这个东西上编程，对吧？
Cause this is really impressive. I wonder if they have a YouTube video. No, that'd be cool. So, I mean, I just kind of like have this like thing, like teaching. So I have a daughter now, she's just a year old, but I have like this grandiose vision of like teaching her to program on this thing, right?
是啊，是啊，完全。就像，哦，我打算，就像，只是在这里，这是你如何做你的指令集。这是你如何用数字编程。在这里我们要学习。哦，我不知道。也许那可能完全不现实。可能完全只是让她对，就像，永远不想做这个感到厌烦。所以如果你去 YouTube，你输入 digicomp2，但用两个 I，
Yeah, yeah, totally. Like, oh, I'm going to like just here, this is how you do your instruction set. And here's how you program in the numbers. And here we're going to learn. Oh, I don't know. Maybe that's probably completely unrealistic. Probably completely just turn her off of like ever wanting to do this. So if you go on YouTube and you type digicomp2, but with two you do two I's,
就像 2 的罗马数字，你实际上会看到一个来自 Evil Mad Scientist 团队的视频，他们组装了一个巨大的 Digicomp 2 版本。哦，所以他们在使用台球。是啊，在这种情况下，他们在使用 8 号球。什么？那太疯狂了。而且他们有一个绝对巨大的，而且我假设，是啊，在某个时候他们会向你展示如何。
like the Roman numeral for 2, you'll actually see a video from the Evil Mad Scientist team where they've assembled a gigantic version of Digicomp 2. Oh, so they're using pool balls. Yeah, in this case they're using eight balls. What? That's crazy. And they have an absolutely gigantic, and I'm assuming, yeah, at some point they'll show you how.
哦，所以，是啊，所以你可以设置指令。所以这就是他们设置他们将要操作的数字的地方。然后他们要打开它，然后球就会开始流过。然后其中一个操作数就会变成答案。对，所以东西会切换位置，然后当它完成后，你可以读取它，计算就完成了。那太神奇了。他们怎么知道有多少球，就像
Oh, so yeah, so you can set the instructions. So this is where they're setting the numbers that they're going to operate on. And then they're going to turn it on, and then the balls will begin to flow through. And then one of the operands will turn into the answer. Right, so things will switch position, and then when it's done, you can read it, and the computation is performed. That is amazing. How do they know how many balls like
哦，是的，所以你可以设置指令。这就是他们设置要操作的数字的地方。然后他们会打开开关，球就会开始流动。接着其中一个操作数会变成答案。没错，东西会变换位置，完成后你就可以读取它，计算就完成了。这太神奇了。他们怎么知道需要多少个球呢？
how many cycles so i think so typically that so they actually ask so it depends on exactly what instruction is being said but they said typically 30 so when it finishes i think essentially there's a ball that hits the off switch and it stops the flow of balls at the right time and then you know so it's like only kind of like one as like each ball flows through it kind of triggers the next ball right so eventually when the operation is finished, that no longer happens. So that's the final thing. That's how you know the statement is over. Oh, this is amazing.
多少个周期，我想通常是这样，他们实际上会问，这取决于具体执行的是什么指令，但他们说通常是30个。所以当它完成时，我想本质上有一个球撞到了关闭开关，它在正确的时间停止了球的流动，然后你知道，就像每个球流过时它都会触发下一个球，对吧？所以最终当操作完成时，这种情况就不会再发生了。这就是最后一步。这就是你怎么知道语句结束了。哦，这太神奇了。
Yeah, you guys have to watch this video. It's not amazing to sit here and watch us talk about it. Yeah, I'll also link the video. Watch us talk about it. Wow. No. Listen to us talk about it. Yeah.
是的，你们一定要看这个视频。坐在这里听我们谈论它并不神奇。是的，我也会附上视频链接。看我们谈论它。哇。不。听我们谈论它。是的。
Okay, anyways. Cool. So I don't know about you. I think you did. We talked about this on our earlier show. But I made a lot of games for the calculator. Did you do this? Yes.
好吧，总之。酷。我不知道你怎么样。我想你做过。我们在之前的节目里谈过这个。但我为计算器做了很多游戏。你做过吗？是的。
You told us about your cheating. I mean, creative. Yes, I did as well. You told us about our RPG on my calculator. Oh, I also made an RPG. And one funny thing was I knew just enough about regression models to sort of get by so I had a quadratic regression That I did on the calculator to to fit a function curve to like a set of points So I kind of knew that like somebody at level 13 should have like this many HP and somebody level 15 should have this many HP
你告诉过我们你作弊的事。我是说，有创意。是的，我也做过。你告诉过我们你在计算器上做的RPG游戏。哦，我也做过一个RPG。有一件有趣的事是，我刚好懂一点回归模型，足以应付过去，所以我用计算器做了一个二次回归，把函数曲线拟合到一组点上。所以我大概知道，比如13级的人应该有这么多生命值，15级的人应该有这么多生命值。
So I kind of like did like some some some testing on my own at different levels to sort of figure out good values. And then I use like a regression curve to like, and then I did not do that. So, so, so, so as an artifact of using this regression curve, the levels and everything, even the monsters levels could go up to infinity because it would just like follow the curve um and so i had people like like like classmates of mine saying dude once you get to level like 57 this game's impossible and i'm like uh i only designed for it to go to like 13 he's like yeah he's like at first i was fighting like and i used also the text like like, Chromantic meant, like, five times the level, you know? So he's like, I was fighting, like, Chromantic, like, insane, like, hardcore black dragons.
所以我自己做了一些不同等级的测试，以找出好的数值。然后我用了回归曲线，然后我没有那样做。所以，作为使用这条回归曲线的产物，等级和一切，甚至怪物的等级都可以上升到无穷大，因为它只是跟随曲线。所以我的同学说，伙计，一旦你到了57级，这个游戏就不可能玩了，我说，我只设计到13级。他说，是的，他说起初我在战斗，我用了像“Chromantic”这样的文本，比如等级的五倍，你知道吗？所以他说，我在和疯狂的、硬核的黑龙战斗。
And all of a sudden I was fighting random characters because I couldn't generate the name for these guys. And he's like, and then the game got impossible. You need to fix it. I was like, how many hours did you spend? He's like, I don't know, like, hundreds. But, yeah. And then he filed a bug report against your code, right? Yeah, exactly. I'm like, I'm 13.
突然间我在和随机角色战斗，因为我无法为这些人生成名字。他说，然后游戏变得不可能玩了。你需要修复它。我说，你花了多少小时？他说，我不知道，几百小时吧。但是，是的。然后他提交了一个针对你代码的错误报告，对吧？是的，完全正确。我说，我才13岁。
And then he threw you in the trash can. Yeah, he just filed a bug report against my face. So somebody actually made a clone or a game inspired by Portal on their calculator, on their graphing calculator. And so it looks pretty awesome. You actually have eight directional controls, so I'm assuming he's using the keypad to shoot the laser and then maybe the left-right.
然后他把你扔进了垃圾桶。是的，他只是针对我的脸提交了一个错误报告。所以有人在他们的计算器上，在他们的图形计算器上制作了一个克隆版或受《传送门》启发的游戏。看起来非常棒。你实际上有八个方向控制，所以我假设他用键盘来发射激光，然后可能是左右移动。
The portal gun. Oh, right, the portal gun, and then the left-right to move around. But yeah, you should see this. It's pretty awesome. If you're a. Oh, right, the portal gun. And then the left, right to move around. But yeah, you should see this. It's pretty awesome. If you're a fan of like, if you have a graphing calculator, you could probably get this on there somehow. So it's all written in TI basic. And I think there's a, does he have a web version?
传送门枪。哦，对了，传送门枪，然后左右移动。但是，是的，你应该看看这个。它非常棒。如果你是……哦，对了，传送门枪。然后左右移动。但是，是的，你应该看看这个。它非常棒。如果你是……如果你有图形计算器，你可能可以通过某种方式把它弄到上面。它完全是用TI Basic编写的。我想，他有网页版吗？
Oh, no, I don't think so. So it runs on the TI-83 or the TI-84. Ah, OK. I believe the TI-83 or the TI-84. Ah, okay. I believe the TI-83 and the TI-84, shameless plug here, and the TI-84 are emulated by MESS. Because that's what I wanted to do. Which is a project I work on my spare time. So you can actually play this in MESS, I'm assuming.
哦，不，我不这么认为。所以它在TI-83或TI-84上运行。啊，好的。我相信TI-83或TI-84。啊，好的。我相信TI-83和TI-84，这里厚颜无耻地打个广告，TI-84是由MESS模拟的。因为那是我想要做的。这是我在业余时间从事的一个项目。所以我假设你实际上可以在MESS中玩这个。
I haven't tried it, but if you could download it, you could probably play it on MESS. If we do that, I'll let you know. So for all those people with time to waste in their math classes yeah totally this is from you this is way better than ti Mario which is what I remember from from my high school classes all right so now it's time for tool of the show tool of the show yeah we dropped that we dropped the bye week yeah we dropped the bye week.
我还没试过，但如果你能下载它，你可能可以在MESS上玩。如果我们这样做，我会让你知道。所以对于所有那些在数学课上浪费时间的人，是的，完全正确，这比我高中课上记得的TI马里奥好多了。好了，现在是节目工具时间，节目工具，是的，我们取消了休赛周，是的，我们取消了休赛周。
Yeah, we dropped the bye week. Sometimes, you know, I think this week, it's actually been less than two weeks. No. Has it not been? Man, time flies. Basically what happens is we're operating on dog time, like dog years. Like every week is really eight weeks. So I don't know.
是的，我们取消了休赛周。有时候，你知道，我想这周，实际上还不到两周。不。不是吗？天哪，时间过得真快。基本上发生的事情是我们按照狗的时间，像狗年一样运作。就像每一周实际上是八周。所以我不知道。
I'm making that up. That doesn't make sense. I think that's the opposite. We, I don't know. I'm making that up. That doesn't make sense. Yeah. I think that's the opposite. We need something that runs slower. Yeah, but I think, like, the outside world is going at eight weeks, but we feel like it's a week
我在胡编乱造。这说不通。我想那是相反的。我们，我不知道。我在胡编乱造。这说不通。是的。我想那是相反的。我们需要一些运行得更慢的东西。是的，但我认为，外面的世界是在以八周的速度前进，但我们觉得这只是一周。
because we're really busy. Okay, so that would be something that lives a long time. Oh, yeah. So, we're the dogs. What? I don't know. Stop, stop.
因为我们真的很忙。好吧，那将是寿命很长的东西。哦，是的。所以，我们是狗。什么？我不知道。停，停。
This is going downhill. So, the tool're the dogs. What? Stop, stop. This is going downhill. So the tool of the show. My tool of the show is... He said all that to say we're really busy. We're sorry we don't get these out more often. Yeah, yeah, definitely. I want to try and keep it more regular. So we're going to try to keep it on a two-week schedule.
这正在走下坡路。所以，工具……我们是狗。什么？停，停。这正在走下坡路。所以节目工具。我的节目工具是……他说了这么多只是为了说我们真的很忙。很抱歉我们没有更频繁地发布这些内容。是的，是的，绝对。我想尝试保持更规律。所以我们将尝试保持两周一次的进度。
But, you know, it's pretty erotic right now. So Cocos2DX and Cocos2DHTML5. These are my tools of the show. DAN GALPIN- Like hot cocoa? DAN GALPIN- Very much so. They're both steaming hot. And so a little bit of history here. So it started off as Cocos2D, which was a Python game
但是，你知道，现在很忙。所以Cocos2DX和Cocos2DHTML5。这些是我的节目工具。DAN GALPIN- 像热可可吗？DAN GALPIN- 非常像。它们都热气腾腾。所以这里有一点历史。它最初是Cocos2D，这是一个Python游戏。
library for programming on the desktop. And then when the iPhone came out, they made Cocos2DIphone, which was written in Objective-C for the iPhone. But it had a very similar API. And a lot of the functions, a lot of the things you could do were the same. That got really popular. It became the number one game development environment for
用于桌面编程的库。然后当iPhone出来时，他们制作了Cocos2DIphone，它是用Objective-C为iPhone编写的。但它有一个非常相似的API。很多功能，很多你能做的事情都是一样的。这变得非常流行。它成为了iPhone上排名第一的游戏开发环境。
iPhone for a long time. They made a Cocos 2D Android. There's a whole bunch of Cocos 2D everything. Then somebody had this genius idea. And the genius idea is you can run JavaScript on iPhone because you can compile the
很长一段时间。他们制作了Cocos 2D Android。有一大堆Cocos 2D的东西。然后有人有了这个天才的想法。天才的想法是你可以在iPhone上运行JavaScript，因为你可以编译。
JavaScript interpreter on the iPhone. Yeah, you can run JavaScript on iPhone. You can run JavaScript on Android, and you can run JavaScript on the browser, obviously. So we just make a system or a set of, like, a framework so that you write your code in JavaScript, and it'll run on the browser, the Android, the iPhone, and, like, 10 other things all for free.
iPhone上的JavaScript解释器。是的，你可以在iPhone上运行JavaScript。你可以在Android上运行JavaScript，显然你可以在浏览器上运行JavaScript。所以我们只是制作一个系统或一套框架，这样你就可以用JavaScript编写代码，它就可以在浏览器、Android、iPhone和其他10种东西上免费运行。
And that's what Cocos2DX is. And so it's pretty awesome. I mean, one of the cool things about it is you can write in Cocos2DHTML5 and you can test and do all your testing and development on the desktop. In the browser. Yeah, in the browser window.
这就是Cocos2DX。所以它非常棒。我的意思是，它很酷的一点是你可以用Cocos2DHTML5编写，你可以在桌面上进行所有的测试和开发。在浏览器里。是的，在浏览器窗口里。
You can show it to your friends. You can be like, hey, go to mycoolwebpage.com and check out my game or whatever. So they can play it, you know. Once you've sort of to your friends you can be like hey go to my cool webpage.com and check out my game or whatever so they can play it you know once you've sort of got like you know a prototype something that work you feel pretty you know confident about then you can just go to the iphone or android um back ends and it's most of it just works nice yeah so you'll have to change the ui obviously because you're going from a mouse to a touchscreen. So you might have to change some stuff there. But the vast majority of the code
你可以把它展示给你的朋友。你可以说，嘿，去mycoolwebpage.com看看我的游戏什么的。所以他们可以玩，你知道。一旦你……给你的朋友看，你可以说嘿，去mycoolwebpage.com看看我的游戏什么的，所以他们可以玩，你知道，一旦你有了原型，一些能工作的东西，你感觉很有信心，然后你就可以去iPhone或Android后端，大部分东西都能直接运行，很好。是的，所以你显然必须改变UI，因为你是从鼠标转向触摸屏。所以你可能需要在那里改变一些东西。但绝大多数代码。
stays the same, which is totally awesome. So highly recommended if you want to do any game programming on mobile. COLT MCANLISLEIGH- Very cool. I have another non-open source tool. Surprise! All right, so mine is Snapseed. So Snapseed used to be pay and is now free on both Android and iOS.
保持不变，这太棒了。所以如果你想在移动设备上进行任何游戏编程，强烈推荐。COLT MCANLISLEIGH- 非常酷。我还有另一个非开源工具。惊喜！好吧，我的是Snapseed。所以Snapseed以前是付费的，现在在Android和iOS上都是免费的。
And it is a photo editing application for your devices, your mobile devices. And this is produced by a company, Nick Software, who I think recently was bought by Google. But Nick Software, they do actually really high-end Photoshop plugins, and they're really expensive, and they're really well-recognized among professionals, but Snapseed is a really intuitive, easy way for you to kind of like do, think like if you ever used Picasa, like think like Picasa, but like on your phone, like, oh, auto-correct the colors, auto-correct the exposure, apply these filters, those kinds of things.
它是一个用于你的设备，你的移动设备的照片编辑应用程序。这是由一家公司Nick Software生产的，我想最近被谷歌收购了。但是Nick Software，他们确实做非常高端的Photoshop插件，它们非常昂贵，在专业人士中非常受认可，但Snapseed是一个非常直观、简单的方式，让你，想想如果你曾经用过Picasa，就像Picasa，但在你的手机上，比如，自动校正颜色，自动校正曝光，应用这些滤镜，诸如此类的事情。
And I was testing it on my Nexus 7 earlier. I also have it on my iPad. And wow, that sounds like really bad. I shouldn't say things like that. Like, oh, I have it on all of these 10 devices. Well, everyone knows you just total. It balances us out though, because I am not a technophile at all.
我之前在我的Nexus 7上测试过它。我也在我的iPad上有它。天哪，这听起来真的很糟糕。我不应该说那样的话。比如，哦，我有这10个设备。好吧，大家都知道你只是……但这平衡了我们，因为我根本不是一个技术发烧友。
Well, that's not a right word of saying it. I like tech, but I don't like gadgets. Like I'm not a gadgetophile at all well that's not a right word of saying it i like tech but i don't like gadgets like i'm not a gadgetophile if that's a word uh so i you know i just got the smartphone not too long ago and like i'm a late adopter to like almost all tech so um gadgets so uh we make a good compliment we compliment each other so for everything i don't have you have oh it's not actually showing i was trying to show Jason, but it's not. So wait, what are you trying to do? So this is like I have a picture here open. This is going to be really boring to everybody.
好吧，那不是一个正确的说法。我喜欢技术，但我不喜欢小玩意。我根本不是一个“小玩意发烧友”，如果这是一个词的话。所以我，你知道，我不久前才买了智能手机，我几乎对所有技术都是晚期采用者，所以……小玩意，所以我们是一个很好的互补，我们互补。所以对于我没有的一切，你有。哦，它实际上没有显示，我试图给Jason看，但没有。等等，你想做什么？所以这就像我这里打开了一张照片。这对每个人来说都会非常无聊。
So you can just apply things. And you drag left and right to adjust. Oh, that's cool. Change the brightness. Up and down to select what you're adjusting. So here I'm adding more grain to make it look like film. So he's showing me a picture of his daughter that is just turning into like a zombie with all these. It's kind of weirding me out. Sorry. Don't offend. You're unoffended. You're making fun of his daughter that is just turning into like a zombie with all these crazy effects. It's kind of weirding me out.
所以你可以直接应用东西。你向左或向右拖动来调整。哦，那很酷。改变亮度。上下选择你要调整的内容。所以在这里我添加了更多的颗粒感，让它看起来像胶片。所以他正在给我看他女儿的照片，照片里的人因为所有这些效果正在变成僵尸。这让我觉得有点怪。抱歉。不要冒犯。你没被冒犯。你正在取笑他女儿，她因为所有这些疯狂的效果正在变成僵尸。这让我觉得有点怪。
Sorry. Don't offend. You're unoffended. You're making fun of my daughter. No, that looks really cool, though. Can you do like – so one common thing that I want to do in pictures is blur out like my license plate, let's say. So, for example, I took a picture – Do I want to ask why you want to blur stuff out in all your pictures?
抱歉。不要冒犯。你没被冒犯。你正在取笑我女儿。不，那看起来真的很酷。你能做……所以我在照片中想做的一件常见的事情是模糊掉我的车牌，比方说。所以，例如，我拍了一张照片——我想问为什么你想在所有的照片中模糊掉东西吗？
So, anyways, I don't know. We can look into that. I don't know. I took a picture of the back of my car to show I was carrying some really heavy things in my car. Now you're like sticking out the top of the car. And I wanted to blur the license plate of the car in the picture. And so will this do that kind of thing too? Maybe.
所以，总之，我不知道。我们可以研究一下。我不知道。我拍了一张我车后的照片，以显示我在车里装了一些非常重的东西。现在你就像从车顶伸出来一样。我想模糊照片中汽车的车牌。这也能做到那种事情吗？也许吧。
I don't know. I haven't looked at that. That's very specific. I don't know. This does like general correcting and color correction, that kind of stuff. It works really well. It's very specific. I don't know. This does general correcting and color correction, that kind of stuff. It works really well. It's really intuitive. It's one of those things where instead of just porting the phone version
我不知道。我还没看过。那非常具体。我不知道。这做的是一般的校正和颜色校正，诸如此类的事情。它工作得非常好。它非常具体。我不知道。这做的是一般的校正和颜色校正，诸如此类的事情。它工作得非常好。它非常直观。它是那种不仅仅是移植手机版本的东西。
or the desktop version, and they really tried to go a little bit farther with the interface and make it more intuitive about what you're supposed to do and how to do it. And, yeah, check it out. I mean, it's free, right? Like, you know, can't be that terrible if you can check it out for free. Well, I guess it could be terrible, but it doesn't allow a lot of risk to you. So, okay, now you're trying it.
或者桌面版本，他们真的试图在界面上走得更远，让它更直观，关于你应该做什么以及如何做。而且，是的，看看它。我的意思是，它是免费的，对吧？你知道，如果你可以免费查看它，它不可能那么糟糕。好吧，我想它可能很糟糕，但它不会给你带来太大的风险。好吧，现在你在尝试它。
Now Jason will not be paying attention for the rest of the show. It's very grungy. I chose grunge, and it definitely feels, I feel like that's pretty... Industrial grungy picture. It's a pretty grungy tree. Yeah, alright, so he's trying it with the default picture. Okay. So, yeah, so check it out, Snapseed. All one word. You can check it. We have a link to Snapseed.com, yeah. Check it out.
现在Jason在节目的剩余时间里都不会注意了。它非常粗糙。我选择了垃圾摇滚风格，它绝对感觉，我觉得那很……工业垃圾风格的照片。这是一棵相当粗糙的树。是的，好吧，所以他正在用默认图片尝试它。好的。所以，是的，看看Snapseed。都是一个词。你可以查看。我们有一个Snapseed.com的链接，是的。看看它。
Snapseed. All one word. You can check it. We have a link to Snapseed.com, which I assume has one to both the iOS App Store and the Play Store. Yeah. So, yeah. For all those devices you guys may or may not have. Cool. If you don't have them, I guess it's not helpful.
Snapseed。都是一个词。你可以查看。我们有一个Snapseed.com的链接，我假设它有一个通往iOS App Store和Play Store的链接。是的。所以，是的。对于你们可能拥有或可能没有的所有那些设备。酷。如果你没有它们，我想这没什么帮助。
But, yes. Yeah, yeah. Well, it supports the ones you have and the ones you don't have. It's pretty cool. And it's cool because sometimes you take a picture and it just didn't turn out quite right. And you want to just fix it a little bit before you send it out or post it on a social network or whatever. Yeah, that's great. That's amazing.
但是，是的。是的，是的。好吧，它支持你拥有的和你不拥有的。它很酷。而且它很酷，因为有时你拍了一张照片，它并没有完全拍好。你想在发送它或发布到社交网络或任何地方之前稍微修复一下。是的，那太棒了。那太神奇了。
So we're starting something new this show. Yeah, totally. Something new, 22 episodes in. I know. We should have done this episode once. A great idea. Wow. Wow.
所以我们在这个节目中开始了一些新的东西。是的，完全正确。一些新的东西，22集了。我知道。我们应该在第一集就做这个。一个好主意。哇。哇。
Jason's tuning his horn. I'm already happy about this. So a lot of people, you know, message, email us, post on our G+, and they say, you know, I want to get into programming. How do I do it? Or, you know, I want more resources on programming. You guys don't yak enough. Yeah, exactly.
Jason在调他的号角。我已经为此感到高兴了。所以很多人，你知道，发消息，发邮件给我们，在我们的G+上发帖，他们说，你知道，我想进入编程。我该怎么做？或者，你知道，我想要更多关于编程的资源。你们聊得不够多。是的，完全正确。
And so, you know, one thing about this show, we can't say, like, oh, and then type C out this. Because that would be the most boring episode ever. No one would want to listen to that. I wouldn't want to listen to myself saying that. So, you know, we started talking about things at a high level. But the reality is for somebody to just start coding, they also need some help. They need some resources, like some text that they can look at.
所以，你知道，关于这个节目的一件事，我们不能说，哦，然后输入C out这个。因为那将是有史以来最无聊的一集。没人想听那个。我不想听我自己说那个。所以，你知道，我们开始从高层次谈论事情。但现实是，对于某人来说，要开始编码，他们也需要一些帮助。他们需要一些资源，比如他们可以看的文本。
And so we are starting the book of the show book of the show book of the show where Jason and I recommend a book for you to read check out this book it's gonna be awesome oh yeah yeah so I think everybody's tuned out now just you and me what is that guy called the guy who busts through the wall goes oh the Kool-Aid man oh is it the Kool-A and goes, oh, yeah. The Kool-Aid man? Is it the Kool-Aid man? Yes. Yeah.
所以我们正在开始节目之书，节目之书，节目之书，Jason和我为你推荐一本书去读，看看这本书，它会很棒。哦，是的，是的，所以我认为每个人现在都调频了，只有你和我，那个冲破墙壁的人叫什么，哦，Kool-Aid人，哦，是Kool-A，然后说，哦，是的。Kool-Aid人？是Kool-Aid人吗？是的。是的。
We need the Kool-Aid man guest speaker for Book of the Show. I will insert that sound effect here. Oh, yeah. Oh, okay. No, that was just still Jason. No, that was me again. Okay. So Book of the Show.
我们需要Kool-Aid人作为节目之书的演讲嘉宾。我会在这里插入那个音效。哦，是的。哦，好的。不，那仍然是Jason。不，那又是我。好的。所以节目之书。
Keep in mind, we're going to provide links for you to buy these books. And we're going to set this up through the Amazon affiliate program. So running the podcast actually costs us a significant amount of money. And it also costs host Tornado, who's our benevolent benefactors, or we're their benefactors of their bandwidth. There are a lot of Bs in that statement. So what Jason's trying to say here, I'll break it down into plain English. He's saying, yeah, so I mean, there are some expenses associated with this show.
请记住，我们将提供链接供你购买这些书。我们将通过亚马逊联盟计划来设置这个。所以运营播客实际上花费了我们大量的钱。这也花费了主持人Tornado，他们是我们的仁慈赞助人，或者我们是他们带宽的赞助人。那个陈述中有很多B。所以Jason在这里想说的是，我把它分解成简单的英语。他说，是的，所以我的意思是，这个节目有一些相关的费用。
And, you know, to help offset that, we're going to try to recommend some stuff that we think is useful for you guys. Yeah, totally. And if you, you know, if you do decide you want one of these books, if Amazon has a good price and, you know, delivers in a good manner to where you live and you'd be interested in buying it that way, that would help out the show and we'd appreciate that yeah i mean just to put things in perspective we used uh what can you add these add these numbers and off top of your head no like 80 is about 200 this is about it's like uh like a terabyte yeah we used about a terabyte of bandwidth um uh last last month alone so that's that's a lot of bandwidth. And so, yeah, so if you are going to buy these books or you're interested, please, please help us out. Buy them through the Amazon link that we provide.
而且，你知道，为了帮助抵消这一点，我们将尝试推荐一些我们认为对你们有用的东西。是的，完全正确。如果你，你知道，如果你确实决定想要这些书中的一本，如果亚马逊有一个好的价格，而且，你知道，以一种好的方式送到你住的地方，并且你有兴趣那样购买，那将有助于节目，我们会感激的。是的，我的意思是，为了把事情放在透视中，我们使用了……你能把这些数字加起来吗？不用动脑子。不，像80大约是200，这大约是……就像……一TB。是的，我们仅上个月就使用了大约一TB的带宽。所以那是非常多的带宽。所以，是的，所以如果你要买这些书或者你感兴趣，请，请帮助我们。通过我们提供的亚马逊链接购买它们。
That would be awesome. But in general, we're going to recommend these books. If they haven't met your library and you want to get them that way, I mean, that's totally cool, right? These are things that we think are good resources in general for you to consider looking at yeah we're not going to tell we're not going to show you either like we're not going to just recommend anything
那将是太棒了。但总的来说，我们将推荐这些书。如果它们没有达到你的图书馆，你想通过那种方式获得它们，我的意思是，那完全没问题，对吧？这些是我们认为对你来说通常是好的资源，可以考虑看看。是的，我们不会告诉……我们也不会向你展示，就像我们不会只是推荐任何东西。
like if we don't have a book we won't recommend it and uh we're only going to recommend books that we've at least read most of so yes uh and we know are good so anyways without any further ado my first book of the show is algorithms in c++ by++ by Robert Sedgwick. This book got me all through college. It's an amazing book. So it does algorithms in C++, but if you're like a Python or a Java coder, you shouldn't worry. You'll have to learn basic C++ to know what's going on, but that shouldn't be too bad. And the nice thing about C++ is there's no hidden complexity. So, you know, if he did algorithms in Java, and I think actually there is an algorithms in Java book, and they are pretty good about not doing this, but you could see the case
就像如果我们没有书，我们就不会推荐它，而且我们只会推荐我们至少读过大部分的书。所以是的，我们知道它们很好。所以总之，不再多说，我的第一本节目之书是Robert Sedgwick的《C++算法》。这本书让我读完了整个大学。这是一本很棒的书。所以它用C++做算法，但如果你是Python或Java程序员，你不应该担心。你必须学习基本的C++才能知道发生了什么，但这应该不会太糟糕。C++的好处是没有隐藏的复杂性。所以，你知道，如果他用Java做算法，我想实际上有一本Java算法书，而且他们做得很好，没有这样做，但你可以看到这种情况。
where someone's like, oh, you know, there's a for loop. And so because of that, it's order, it takes n time because you have a for loop. And so because of that, it takes n time because you have a for loop. But the reality is inside that for loop, you're calling some Java function, like collections.sort, which takes n log n. So some languages that have a lot of, as you say, batteries included can hide the complexity, which is nice, but in this case is bad.
有人说，哦，你知道，有一个for循环。所以因为那个，它是顺序的，它需要n时间，因为你有一个for循环。所以因为那个，它需要n时间，因为你有一个for循环。但现实是，在那个for循环内部，你正在调用一些Java函数，比如collections.sort，它需要n log n。所以一些有很多，正如你所说的，包含电池的语言可以隐藏复杂性，这很好，但在这种情况下是坏的。
So by using C++. I think most algorithm books are pretty good about not doing that. Because that kind of obscures what you're trying to learn. Yep, totally. But this algorithm is the C++. C++ is a good language for doing this kind of stuff in. And he goes through the code pretty thoroughly.
所以通过使用C++。我想大多数算法书在不这样做方面做得很好。因为那掩盖了你试图学习的东西。是的，完全正确。但这个算法是C++。C++是做这种事情的好语言。他非常彻底地讲解了代码。
Has many different categories. I think there's one book where the whole book is just graph theory. So this is five books oh that's right so it's actually oh well it's confusing it's two books but one book has parts one through five in it or one through four in it and the second book has part five so a little confusing wow okay that's that's not a little confusing dude that's very good yeah it's very confusing so confusion aside book is totally worth it even then um so i actually realized we should have done a different book based on our topic today. But we'll save that for another day.
有很多不同的类别。我想有一本书整本书都是图论。所以这是五本书，哦，那是对的，所以实际上……哦，好吧，这很令人困惑，它是两本书，但一本书里有第1到5部分，或者第1到4部分，第二本书有第5部分，所以有点令人困惑。哇，好的，那……那不是有点令人困惑，伙计，那非常令人困惑。是的，它非常令人困惑。所以撇开困惑不谈，书完全值得，即使那样。所以实际上我意识到我们应该根据我们今天的主题做一本不同的书。但我们会把它留到另一天。
You can change. No, that's okay. I like mine. All right. You're going to steal it if I don't do it. Okay. So what's your book of the show? My book of the show, which I'm not changing because I like it.
你可以改变。不，没关系。我喜欢我的。好吧。如果你不做，你就会偷走它。好的。所以你的节目之书是什么？我的节目之书，我不会改变，因为我喜欢它。
This book is awesome. Actually, we've both read this book. Yes, this is good so so um jason did something algorithms i mean that's very technical that's very like you know high level so something else which um i think sometimes people think it's a very complicated topic but it's really not it's kind of one of those things where is so algorithms are something where you wouldn't necessarily think to do that on your own i mean if you're really smart maybe you would and maybe some of the algorithms are kind of like
这本书太棒了。实际上，我们都读过这本书。是的，这很好。所以……Jason做了一些算法，我的意思是，那非常技术性，那非常像，你知道，高层次。所以还有别的东西，我想有时人们认为这是一个非常复杂的话题，但它真的不是。它有点像那种……所以算法是那种你未必会自己想去做的事情。我的意思是，如果你真的很聪明，也许你会，也许有些算法有点像……
a natural outcropping of something you would already do, and it's just formalizing. But it really is like aha moments. Like, I didn't know. That's how you would find the distance to the closest thing in the graph or the shortest path between two points, nodes in a graph.
你本来就会做的事情的自然产物，它只是形式化。但它确实像“啊哈”时刻。就像，我不知道。这就是你如何找到图中到最近事物的距离，或者图中两点、节点之间的最短路径。
Those kind of things are, you can sit down and work out something, but it is really teaching you the formalization of it and also new techniques. Yeah, like often you might have some problem and there's some brute force way to solve anything, right? So pretty much almost any problem, there's some brute force way to solve it that's really easy to code up, but it'll take, you know, years and years to run. Yeah, and that's when you really need algorithms. But the book you're going to present, you always need yeah so so this is um headfirst design patterns yeah so headfirst design and we have we'll have a link in the show notes and so design patterns we've
那些事情是，你可以坐下来算出一些东西，但它确实是在教你它的形式化，以及新的技术。是的，就像通常你可能会遇到一些问题，并且有某种暴力破解方法来解决任何事情，对吧？所以几乎任何问题，都有某种暴力破解方法来解决它，编码起来非常容易，但它需要，你知道，几年才能运行。是的，那就是你真正需要算法的时候。但你将要介绍的书，你总是需要……是的，所以这是……《Head First设计模式》。是的，Head First设计，我们会有链接在节目说明中。所以设计模式，我们被问到过一点，也许我们会在节目中做，但我的意思是，设计模式，很多……就像我第一次听到时，我想，哇，这听起来很疯狂，人们谈论像彻底改变他们编码的方式，我的意思是，我不是说那些人错了或不理会他们。我的意思是，它可能是。我的意思是，它在某种程度上对我来说就是那样。就像它能够教我识别我在代码中正在做但我没有意识到的事情。稍微改变它们，使它们成为更被普遍接受的方法，或者稍微改进它们。但它是什么，设计模式实际上是找到共同的主题和事情。
been asked about a little bit maybe we'll do it in a show but i mean design patterns a lot of them like when i first heard i was like whoa like this sounds crazy and people talk about like revolutionizing the way they do coding and i mean I don't mean to say those people are wrong or discount them. I mean, it could be. I mean, it was in some way for me that. Like it was able to teach me to recognize things in my code that I was doing and I wasn't aware of. Change them slightly to make them more kind of generally accepted approach or refine them slightly. But what it is is design patterns is really kind of finding common themes and things
你需要做的事情在你的代码中。并形式化它们，说，嘿，这是一个做这个的好方法。所以人们想到的最常见的一个，至少我认为大多数人想到的是，是单例。所以那是你学习的第一个。什么是单例？然后如果你听说过这个概念。
you need to do in your code. And formalizing them, saying like, hey, here's a really good way to do this. So kind of the most common one people think about is, at least I think most people think about, is the singleton. So that's the first one you learn about. What is a singleton? And then if you hear about this concept
如果你不理解它的结构，你就会错误地使用它。人们有点像，哦，这真的很聪明。就像我学到了大多数语言必须做的这个轻微的编码技巧。然后我用它作为一种方式来做我本不应该做的顽皮事情。但《Head First设计模式》会讲解。它讲解单例。它讲解，你知道，发布订阅，我相信，就在里面。有各种各样的装饰器模式，这些东西是什么，它们意味着什么，有点把……
and you don't understand the structure of it, you kind of use it incorrectly. And people are kind of like, oh, this is really clever. Like I learned this slight coding trick that most languages have to do it. And then I use it as a way to kind of do naughty things that I wasn't supposed to do in other ways. But headfirst design pattern will go through. It goes through singleton. It goes through, you know, publisher subscriber, I believe, is in there. There's all sorts of the decorator pattern what are these things what do they mean kind of taking
面向对象走得更远一点，说，嘿，让我们形式化一些那些结构，提供一种通用的方法来做它们，它们有什么好处，有什么坏处。而且这本书读起来非常有趣，就像……编程书通常非常枯燥，就像，哦，这感觉像读教科书。这一本不是那样的。例子非常有趣，有点像松散的方式。就像，哦，我想开一家披萨店，你知道，我想让人们能够在我的程序中创建新种类的披萨，对吧？这些种类的东西，非常容易，非常现实生活中的东西。还有很多小图片和图画，而且它……它没有教你非常、非常深入、深刻的阅读，
object oriented a little bit farther and saying like hey let's formalize some of those structures provide a common way to do them what they're good for what they're bad for and the book is really interesting to read like it's actually of programming books are normally very cut and dry and like oh this feels like reading a textbook. This one's not like that. The examples are very fun, kind of like loose ways. Like, oh, I want to have a pizza shop and, you know, I want people to be able to create new kinds of pizza in my program, right? These kinds of things, very easy, very real-life kind of things. And lots of little pictures and drawings and kind of – it doesn't teach you the very, very in-depth, deep, deep read,
但它是一本非常容易读的书。所以你可以读完它。你可以得到一个想法，然后说，我想从这里走得更远吗？我想查什么？我想考虑什么？是的，它有一点点那个……我不知道艺术风格是什么，但有点像……你知道你会怎么看，像铆工罗西什么的，对吧？
but it's a very easy read. So you can get through it. You can get an idea and then say, like, do I want to go further from here? What do I want to look up? What do I want to consider? Yeah, and it's got that little bit of that – I don't know what the art style is, but sort of like the – you know how you'd see, like, Rosie the welder or whatever, right?
就像50年代的？哦，好的。是的，在那里她就像……有，就像，只是罗西的图片，然后她说了一些引语，那是铆工罗西。哦，你是对的，罗西，我说了什么？所以铆工罗西，所以它就像罗西的图片，她就像“坚强点，女孩们”什么的，所以他们有这种相同的艺术风格，就像他们有这个家伙，他只是像“是的，编码完全很酷”，他就像……有像黑白图片，这个家伙。是的，我的意思是，它有点……我的意思是，他们没有把自己看得太严肃。
Like from the 50s? Oh, okay. Yeah, where she's like – there's, like, just pictures of Rosie and then she's saying some quote that was rosie the riveter oh you're right rosie what did i say so rosie the riveter so it's like a picture of rosie and she's like be tough girls or whatever and so they they have this same kind of art style like they have this guy who's just like yeah coding is totally cool and he's like there's like a picture like black and white picture this guy. Yeah, I mean, it's a little, I mean, they don't take themselves too seriously.
是的，我认为这很棒。我实际上非常喜欢这种风格。所以，我的意思是，有一个完整的系列，这些Head First的东西。而且很多都非常好。我读过其中的一些。很多都有它。而且封面有一个头巨大的女人。好吧，是的，因为它是一张奇怪的图片。
Yeah, which I think is great. I actually really like the style. So, I mean, there's a whole series, this head first stuff. And a lot of it is really good. I've read some of them. A lot of them have it. And the cover has a woman with a gigantic head. Well, yeah, because it is a strange picture.
但这是因为它首先是头。哦，你知道，那是那种像你……一旦你发现你没得到它，你感觉真的很笨。它是Head First。它是那个头巨大的，当然。好的。总之。所以是的，看看它。你知道，我喜欢它。
But it's because it's head first. Oh, you know, that's one of those things that like you, once you find out that you didn't get it, you feel really dumb. It's head first. It's the one with the gigantic head, of course. Okay. Anyways. So yeah, check it out. You know, I like it.
我读过它。是的，这是一本很棒的书。是的，是的，是的。我的意思是，它可能不会让你通过学校的设计模式课，但它会向你介绍一个话题，提供一个跳板。而且就像我说的，它是一本容易读的书，这在计算机科学书中很少见。而且形式化这些东西是好的。所以，例如，你知道，我下了很多棋，然后最终我到了我去了，像，一个象棋学校。
I've read it. Yeah, it's a great book. Yeah, yeah, yeah. I mean, it's not going to probably get you through a design pattern class in school, but it's going to introduce a topic to you, provide a jumping-off point. And like I said, it's an easy read, which is rare in computer science books. And it's good to formalize these things. So, for example, you know, I played a lot of chess, and then eventually I got to the point where I went to, like, a chess school
或者有人教了我很多象棋。我不知道。是的，我实际上赢得了佛罗里达州锦标赛。不错，我当时17岁。是的，所以……所以然后就像……你不需要和我下棋。哦，所以有些事情我……我做了，你知道，但我真的不知道，你知道，我真的不知道，你知道，正式地知道它们。例如，象棋里有一种东西叫“牵制”，你有像一个棋子，可以像击中敌人的国王，就像它可以得到将死，但有一个棋子挡路，就像对手的一个棋子阻止你将死，对吧？或者阻止国王，好吧，那个棋子就像被牵制了，就像如果他移动那个棋子，那么你就会……
or someone taught me a lot of chess. I didn't know that. Yeah, I actually won the Florida State Championship. nice i was like 17 yeah so and so then it's like there was you didn't have to play me oh so there are things that i uh that i did you know but i didn't really know you know i didn't really know for know them formally like for example there's something in chess called pinning where you have like a piece that could like hit the enemy's king like it could get a checkmate but there's a piece in the way like one of the opponent's pieces is keeping you from checkmating right or from checking the king well that piece is like pinned like if he moves the piece then you would
理论上吃掉他的国王，对吧，赢得比赛。所以那个棋子不能动。所以有你可以做的事情，比如你可以移动到那个棋子本来会攻击的地方，因为你知道它不能动，例如。所以它就像你可能会做这些事情，只是作为一个象棋选手，但并没有真正像完全理解它们，并且像完全理解范围以及你有什么能力，他们如何能摆脱它，而且……所以当我像在象棋中得到正式训练时，它像戏剧性地改善了，超过了我自己正在做的事情。而且它也是一种通用语言，所以现在就像这个牵制概念，我对它一无所知……现在如果你想谷歌那个，你可以查找与牵制相关的策略。是的，现在你知道了，对吧？所以计算机科学要带入这个……像……
take his king in theory right and win the game so that piece can't move and so that there's things you can do like you can move to where that piece would have attacked because you know it can't move for example and so it's like you might do these things like as just a chess player but not really like completely understand them and like completely understand the scope and what you're capable of how they can get out of it and and so when i got like formal training in chess it like improved dramatically like over just things i was doing on my own and it's a common language too so now like this pinning concept of which i do not know anything um would like now if you wanted to google that like you could look up strategies related to pinning yeah now that you know it right so in computer science to bring this like into like a
多一点，如果你不知道什么是单例，实际上单例你可能自己就能弄明白。就像发布或订阅。但发布或订阅。你完全可能会做那个。或者装饰器面板。你完全可能会自己做那些。
little bit more, if you don't know what a singleton is, it's unlikely actually singleton you'd probably figure out on your own. Like publish or subscribe. But publish or subscribe. You totally might do that. Or the decorator panel. You totally might do those on your own.
但现在你知道它叫什么了，你可以看看它，你可以找到做它的新方法或更好的方法。或者如果你有关于它的问题，或者它是做它的正确情况吗？它为你提供了一种与人交谈的语言。是的。而且你可能正在使用，比方说，Java，Java有PubSubs用于他们所有的事件处理，用于他们的GUI，用于Java swing GUI。
But now that you know what it's called, you can look at it and you can find new ways of doing it or better ways of doing it. Or if you have a problem with it or is it the right case to do it. And it provides a language for you to talk to people in. Yeah. And you might be using, let's say, Java and Java has PubSubs for all of their event handling for their GUI, for the Java swing GUI.
通过了解设计模式并知道那是什么，你知道，所以你可以立即看看那个并说，哦，这就是Java正在做的。而且你知道在幕后发生了什么。因为他们可能正在使用设计模式。是的。我的意思是，设计模式可以有多种实现形式。但同样，它们只是它们的模式。而且还有反模式，它们也是设计模式，
By knowing the design pattern and knowing that's what, you know, so you could immediately look at that and say, oh, this is what Java is doing. And you know sort of in like what is going on under the covers. Because they're probably using the design pattern. Yeah. I mean, design patterns can have many forms of implementations. But again, they're just their patterns. And there's also anti-patterns, which are also design patterns,
但它们是你可能不应该使用的。所以像意大利面条代码。我们听过那个术语。好的，那是一个设计模式。它非常常见，但它实际上是一个坏的。你不应该使用……是的，对吧，对吧，所以就像，你知道，意大利面条代码，就像我们听过那个术语，就像，好的，那是一个设计模式，它非常常见，但它实际上是一个坏的，就像你不应该那样做，对吧？是的，好的，是时候谈谈La Tech，La Tech和Tech和Tech了，它不是latex，或者……是的，我用过……我不会撒谎，直到我为这个节目做准备，我总是叫它latex。我实际上叫它latex，直到我的教授，我的导师批评我。他说，不，它是latex。
but they're ones you probably shouldn't be using. So like spaghetti code. We've heard that term. OK, that's a design pattern. It's very common, but it's actually a bad one. You shouldn't do using yeah right right so like you know spaghetti code like we've heard that term like okay that's a design pattern it's very common but it's actually a bad one like you shouldn't do that right yep so all right time for our talk about la tech la tech and tech and tech it's not latex or yeah i used i i won't lie until i was preparing for this show i always called it latex i actually called it latex until my professor, my advisor criticized me. He's like, no, it's latex.
所以……我有点觉得，我知道那是我想象中的通用方式或公认方式，但它有点像那种……它是一个你并没有真正听到说出来的词。你只是读它。而且事情是，尤其是对于Tech来说不是那么多，但对于……或者即使对于Tech，就像你有Tex-Mex食物，对吧？
And so... I kind of feel like, I know that's what I guess is the common way or the accepted way, but it's kind of one of those things like it's a word you don't really hear said. You just read it. And the thing is, especially not so much with tech, but with, or even with tech, like you have Tex-Mex food, right?
或者就像你有乳胶手套，对吧？对。所以，就像，你习惯于以不同的方式使用这个词或以不同的方式说这个词。所以，拼写发音。所以，这是因为tau，epsilon，chi。对。它们是希腊字母，是Tech拼写的方式。而且它们有点……如果你曾经看到它被写出来，它被写出来，它看起来有点滑稽。
Or like you have latex gloves, right? Right. So, like, you're used to using the word a different way or saying the word a different way. So, spelling pronunciations. So, it's because tau, epsilon, chi. Right. Which are Greek letters, is what tech is spelled as. And they're kind of, if you ever see it written, it's written and it looks slightly funny.
是的。那是因为它，你知道，试图展示排版能力，能够写，例如，希腊字母在你的东西里。所以谁写了最初的Tech？Donald Newth。Donald Newth。你知道，我想我已经讲过这个故事一次了，
Yeah. And that's because it's, you know, trying to show the typography capabilities of being able to write, for instance, Greek letters in your stuff. So who wrote the original tech? Donald Newth. Donald Newth. You know, I think I already said this story once,
但那是很多集之前的事了，但我去和Donald Newth同一个验光师那里。是的，我想你做过。我仍然还没有见到他。所以我去过验光师那里。啊，Newth，是的，我想你做过。我仍然还没有见到他。所以我去过验光师那里，我看到你做了什么。啊，完全不是故意的。我见到他了。是的，我只是不断看到我眼前有斑点。不，Donald，所以我实际上认为它是Knuth。哦，这是话题，这就是……发音键所说的。好的，但是……如果你曾经在验光师那里看到他……
but it was many episodes ago, but I go to the same optometrist as Donald Newth. Yes, I think you did. I still have yet to see him. So I've been to optometrists. Ah newth yes i think you did i still have yet to see him so i've been to optometrist i see what you did there ah totally not intentional i get to see him yeah i just keep seeing spots in front of my eyes no donald so i actually think it's knuth as well oh it's topic that's what uh the pronunciation key says okay but uh if you ever see him at the optometrist...
我不认为他能看到我。不，我只是开玩笑。但Donald Knuth相当老了。但是……74岁。74岁。哦，我们不应该谈论人们的别名吗？那不礼貌。
I don't think he could see me. No, I'm just kidding. But Donald Knuth is rather old. But... 74. 74 years old. Oh, we shouldn't talk about people's alias? That's not polite.
好吧，他是一个公众人物。好的。如果维基百科能做到，我们就能做到。那应该是节目上的新规则。那是一个非常危险的规则。是的。所以，是的，Tech是由Donald Knuth写的，我相信他是一位数学教授。
Well, he's a public figure. Okay. If Wikipedia could do it, we could do it. That should be the new rule on the show. That's a very dangerous rule. Yep. So, yeah, tech was written by Donald Knuth, who was a math professor, I believe.
嗯，他是个公众人物。好吧。如果维基百科能做到，我们也能做到。这应该成为节目的新规则。那是一个非常危险的规则。是的。所以，是的，技术是由唐纳德·克努特编写的，我相信他是一位数学教授。
I mean, he's known for his computer science contributions. Right. I think he originally started off in math. All right. And so, yeah, so, I mean, he was writing a book, a kind of famous set of books, Art of Computer Programming. And he was disappointed when he was trying to actually do the second revision of his code with the current technology for printing books, typesetting. So way back in the day with Gutenberg, you would have little letters which were carved,
我的意思是，他以对计算机科学的贡献而闻名。没错。我想他最初是学数学的。好的。所以，是的，我的意思是，他当时正在写一本书，一套很有名的书，《计算机程序设计艺术》。当他试图用当时排版书籍的现有技术进行代码的第二次修订时，他感到很失望。回到古腾堡时代，你会用雕刻的小字母，
and you could move them. And that was the movable type printing press. You could take the block that had the letter carved on it in a specific way and you could move them around to change for each page. And you would bring that whole shelf of letters onto the paper and they would print it, right? But, I mean, it was a long time before we kind of got to where that wasn't the way things were done anymore. Because, I mean, you really require computers to be able to do something digitally to kind of shape the letters or put them on a disk or image it or project it.
你可以移动它们。那就是活字印刷机。你可以拿走那个以特定方式刻有字母的块，然后为了每一页的排版移动它们。你会把整架子的字母放到纸上，然后它们就会被印出来，对吧？但是，我的意思是，在那种方式不再被使用之前，我们经历了很长一段时间。因为，我的意思是，你确实需要计算机才能以数字方式做一些事情，比如塑造字母，或者把它们放在磁盘上，或者成像，或者投影出来。
And that was a relatively modern invention. Mm-hmm. Yeah. Yeah, so he was dissatisfied with the, you know... So one thing with the computers is, like, I mean, you've all seen those, like, old terminals now that you see them in the cash registers as, like, DOS terminals with, like, the DOS box art where it's, like, they've made art out of old characters. Oh, yes, yes, yes.
那是一个相对现代的发明。嗯哼。是的。是的，所以他对那个……你知道……感到不满。所以计算机的一件事是，就像，我的意思是，你们都见过那些旧终端，现在你在收银机里看到的那些，像 DOS 终端，带有 DOS 框艺术，就像，他们用旧字符制作了艺术品。哦，是的，是的，是的。
So, I mean, computers clearly didn't have the flexibility as these printing presses where you could, like, you know, if you wanted to do a subscript, you could just take a smaller number and just put it there because, like, everything was sort of floating in a sense so he was dissatisfied with this and he wrote tech as a way to formally describe you know exactly the typography that he wanted with you know superscripts and subscripts and all sorts of you know formulae formula and things like that so um and then after tech, somebody started writing macros for tech, as you do with any language. As the language grows up, most of C++ is written in C++. We've talked about this. DAN GALPIN- Bootstrapping. DAN GALPIN- Yeah, bootstrapping.
所以，我的意思是，计算机显然没有像这些印刷机那样的灵活性，你可以，就像，你知道，如果你想做一个下标，你可以拿一个较小的数字直接放在那里，因为，就像，一切在某种意义上都是浮动的，所以他对这一点感到不满，他编写了 TeX 作为一种正式描述你想要的排版的方式，你知道，带有上标和下标以及各种各样的公式和类似的东西，所以嗯，然后 TeX 之后，有人开始为 TeX 编写宏，就像你对任何语言所做的那样。随着语言的成长，大部分 C++ 都是用 C++ 编写的。我们谈过这个。DAN GALPIN- 自举。DAN GALPIN- 是的，自举。
So people have written a lot of tech macros to simplify their life. And they'd written so many that it got compiled into something that is now its own program which is essentially tech with all these macros and that's called latech latech and latech is called so because it was made by leslie lamport so um he decided to prepend his the first two letters of his last name called latex. I guess that's your privilege if you make such a large contribution. Yeah, definitely.
所以人们编写了很多 TeX 宏来简化他们的生活。他们写了太多，以至于它被编译成现在它自己的程序，本质上就是带有所有这些宏的 TeX，这被称为 LaTeX。LaTeX 之所以这样命名，是因为它是由 Leslie Lamport 制作的，所以嗯，他决定在他的姓氏前加上前两个字母，称为 LaTeX。我想如果你做出了如此巨大的贡献，那是你的特权。是的，绝对是。
So, I mean, people may not have ever used this before. So it's like me, I've heard about this a lot. I haven't very, very rarely used it. And people just think, oh, this is like Word? And it's like, well, kind of. Part of what Word does is related to this yep yeah so um so yeah one thing that really separates us from word is you know Microsoft Word and like similar products they call them WYSIWYG which
所以，我的意思是，人们可能以前从未使用过这个。所以就像我一样，我听说过很多次。我很少很少使用它。人们只是认为，哦，这就像 Word 吗？就像，嗯，算是吧。Word 所做的一部分与此有关，是的，是的，所以嗯，所以是的，真正将我们与 Word 分开的一件事是，你知道，Microsoft Word 和类似的产品，他们称之为 WYSIWYG，即
means what you see is what you get and so you know with word as you're sort of typing and you go you put an image you drag the image into your Word doc and it's there, right? Like you see the image. You know, you do different things. Like you create a formula and there's a little formula, Microsoft formula editor. And when you're done, the formula is there, like in the page. And you expect when you print it to just look like it does on the screen. Tech is not like that. Tech is what you see is what you mean,
所见即所得，所以你知道，使用 Word 时，当你打字时，你放入一张图片，你把图片拖到你的 Word 文档中，它就在那里，对吧？就像你看到了图片。你知道，你做不同的事情。比如你创建一个公式，有一个小公式，Microsoft 公式编辑器。当你完成后，公式就在那里，就像在页面上一样。你期望当你打印它时，它看起来就像屏幕上显示的那样。TeX 不是那样的。TeX 是“所见即所指”，
which is, I don't know if that's a cop-out. So tech is really a programming language. And the idea is, you know, you program your document. And so, for example, the biggest way in which this is noticeable is with figures. So the way tech works is you have what's called a reference to a figure. So you might be talking about a figure in a document. And then in parentheses you might say, see, and then in the tech code you do slash ref figure one.
这，我不知道这是否是一种逃避。所以 TeX 实际上是一种编程语言。其理念是，你知道，你对你的文档进行编程。所以，例如，这最明显的方式是在图表方面。所以 TeX 的工作方式是你有所谓的图表引用。所以你可能正在谈论文档中的一个图表。然后在括号里你可能会说，参见，然后在 TeX 代码中你输入 \ref。
And then it'll actually change that to see figure one. But you can actually in tech put all of your figures at the bottom of your source file. Like, you could be writing a 300-page book and write all 300 pages of the tech source code, and then at the bottom have three pages of just images. And tech will put your images in the right spot based on your references. So it's a very different paradigm. And in some ways, you're kind of at the mercy of the tech compiler, in the right spot based on your references. So it's a very different paradigm. And in some ways, you're kind of at the mercy of the tech compiler,
然后它实际上会把它改成“参见图 1”。但你实际上可以在 TeX 中把你所有的图表放在源文件的底部。比如，你可以写一本 300 页的书，写完所有 300 页的 TeX 源代码，然后在底部放三页纯图片。TeX 会根据你的引用把你的图片放在正确的位置。所以这是一种非常不同的范式。在某些方面，你有点受 TeX 编译器的摆布，在某些方面，你有点受 TeX 编译器的摆布。
although there are directives you can give it if you really want something a certain way. In some way, you're at the mercy of the compiler. But in other ways, you don't have to think about that stuff. You can put all your figures at the bottom and just say, look, put my figures wherever it looks pleasing. Or you just write your equations and you say look just make this equation work you know so um so it is kind of like an up it's a double-edged sword but uh and yeah i mean so like as like a language like anything it kind of gets adapted and people are
虽然如果你真的想要某种方式，你可以给它指令。在某种程度上，你受编译器的摆布。但在其他方面，你不需要考虑那些事情。你可以把你所有的图表放在底部，然后说，看，把我的图表放在看起来令人愉悦的地方。或者你只是写你的方程，然后说，看，只要让这个方程起作用，你知道，所以嗯，所以它有点像一把双刃剑，但是嗯，是的，我的意思是，就像任何语言一样，它会被改编，人们
using it for very certain things so so you use it fairly frequently, right? Yeah. So you encountered it in academia or before you got to school? Academia, yeah. Okay. So many, almost all academic conferences want you, or even textbooks, things like that, want you to write in LaTeX or Tech. Which is these computer science ones.
用它做非常特定的事情，所以你用得相当频繁，对吧？是的。所以你是在学术界还是在去学校之前接触到它的？学术界，是的。好的。所以很多，几乎所有的学术会议都希望你，甚至教科书，类似的东西，都希望你用 LaTeX 或 TeX 编写。也就是这些计算机科学类的。
Yeah, that's true. I can't speak for, although I believe this is, well, I don't know, actually. I can't speak for outside of computer science. I know computer engineering does. Oh, there you go. So one of the reasons that a lot of people want you to use LaTeX is because you're writing the source code, it actually takes your source code, dot tech file that you write and then it also takes as an input a dot sty file a style file and the style file sort of tells all of those
是的，那是真的。我不能代表，虽然我相信这是，嗯，我不知道，实际上。我不能代表计算机科学以外的领域。我知道计算机工程是这样。哦，原来如此。所以很多人希望你使用 LaTeX 的原因之一是因为你正在编写源代码，它实际上获取你的源代码，你编写的 .tex 文件，然后它还获取一个 .sty 文件，即样式文件作为输入，样式文件有点告诉所有这些
things like what font to use like when like should the chapter headings be this point or that point font should the you know should you have a table of contents or not like the style file can actually tell a tech whether or not to generate a table of contents you might not not have one right so it'll do all this crazy stuff and another thing is a style file short of is a way that keeps the publishers stuff keeps the publishers like IP in a sense. So for example, we talked about headfirst design patterns, right? Well, they have a certain style, a certain font, you know, they have certain like a way their books look and things like that. And that style is private. Even people who, if you were to write a chapter for headfirst design patterns, you still would not have access
事情，比如使用什么字体，比如什么时候，章节标题应该是这个字号还是那个字号的字体，你应该有目录还是没有，比如样式文件实际上可以告诉 TeX 是否生成目录，你可能根本没有，对吧？所以它会做所有这些疯狂的事情，另一件事是样式文件是一种保持出版商的东西，在某种意义上保持出版商的知识产权的方式。例如，我们谈到了《Head First 设计模式》，对吧？嗯，他们有一种特定的风格，特定的字体，你知道，他们有某种他们书看起来的样子等等。而那种风格是私有的。即使是那些，如果你要为《Head First 设计模式》写一章，你仍然无法访问
to their style. Like it would look totally different to you than when it went into print. And so that way, you know, you couldn't just steal their style and like make your own headfirst Patrick Wheeler patterns thing, you know, book. So it's really common in the professional industry for this reason. Another thing is there's something called Bibtex. So is that what you wear when you eat lobster? A bib? No, it's a digital bib.
他们的风格。就像它对你来说看起来与印刷出来时完全不同。所以这样，你知道，你就不能只是窃取他们的风格，然后制作你自己的《Head First Patrick Wheeler 模式》之类的书。所以这在专业行业中非常普遍，原因就在于此。另一件事是有一种东西叫 BibTeX。那是你吃龙虾时穿的东西吗？围兜？不，它是数字围兜。
It's BibTech. A tech bib? A technology bib. That's one with LEDs. Oh, man. I totally want an LED bib. Blue LEDs. That's what Tron would wear if he was eating lobster.
它是 BibTeX。一个 TeX 围兜？一个技术围兜。那是带 LED 的那种。哦，天哪。我真的很想要一个 LED 围兜。蓝色 LED。如果 Tron 吃龙虾，他就会穿那个。
He would be wearing a BibTech. So BibTech is amazing. You can actually go to scholar.google.com, which is a Google scholar, like a research academic paper search. So you can go to scholar.google.com. You can type in Donald Knuth. You'll see a bunch of articles written by him and books and whatnot. And if you wanted to cite one in one of, in something you were writing, you could click on import BibTech
他会戴着 BibTeX。所以 BibTeX 太棒了。你实际上可以去 scholar.google.com，也就是 Google Scholar，像是一个研究学术论文搜索。所以你可以去 scholar.google.com。你可以输入 Donald Knuth。你会看到一堆他写的文章和书之类的。如果你想在你正在写的东西中引用其中一篇，你可以点击导入 BibTeX
and you'll get a dot Bib file. So, you know, you export, export. Oh yeah. Well, you're, you're actually, you're exporting from the article to a snippet of code that you're importing into your tech file. COLT MCANLISTER FOREHERSHERD, Right. Yeah, so I think this Scholar thing actually says import. And what they mean is you can import it anyways. DAN GALPINIUSKAYA, Oh, OK. I see. That's why you were confused.
然后你会得到一个 .bib 文件。所以，你知道，你导出，导出。哦，是的。嗯，你，你实际上，你正在从文章导出到你导入到 TeX 文件中的代码片段。COLT MCANLISTER FOREHERSHERD，对。是的，所以我认为这个 Scholar 东西实际上说的是导入。他们的意思是你可以导入它，无论如何。DAN GALPINIUSKAYA，哦，好的。我明白了。这就是你困惑的原因。
COLT MCANLISTER FOREHERSHERD, Yeah, it's confusing. So you end up with this tech file, this sty file, and all these bib files that you've gotten across the web. And the tech program sort of munches it all together into this document. So it's pretty freaking cool. It can export to many different formats. This is the part I really like.
COLT MCANLISTER FOREHERSHERD，是的，这很令人困惑。所以你最终得到了这个 TeX 文件，这个 sty 文件，以及你从网上获得的所有这些 bib 文件。TeX 程序把它们全部混合在一起，变成了这个文档。所以这非常酷。它可以导出为许多不同的格式。这是我真正喜欢的部分。
So I did my resume in tech. And the reason why is because... Oh, sorry. That's so confusing it sounds like technology. But sorry, go ahead. Your tech resume. In LaTeX. I'm resume. In LaTeX. My resume in LaTeX.
所以我用 TeX 做了我的简历。原因是因为……哦，抱歉。这太令人困惑了，听起来像技术。但是抱歉，请继续。你的 TeX 简历。用 LaTeX。我的简历。用 LaTeX。我的简历用 LaTeX。
And so the reason why is because I can do LaTeX to HTML. It exports to HTML. Put it on your website. Putting it on the website. LaTeX to PDF. It's actually called PDF LaTeX. Okay. Submitting to a website's submission form.
所以原因是因为我可以做 LaTeX 到 HTML。它导出为 HTML。放在你的网站上。放在网站上。LaTeX 到 PDF。它实际上被称为 PDF LaTeX。好的。提交到网站的提交表单。
Yeah, exactly. And I also have on the website, it's like for a PDF version. Oh, download. Yeah, yeah. And so it have on the website, it's like for a PDF version. Oh, download. Yeah, yeah. And so it even does things which I don't really need. There's a DVI format which is basically an image for every page. Just like scrunch, squish together if you need that. There's PostScript if you're
是的，完全正确。而且我在网站上也有，就像 PDF 版本。哦，下载。是的，是的。所以它在网站上也有，就像 PDF 版本。哦，下载。是的，是的。所以它甚至做了一些我并不真正需要的事情。有一种 DVI 格式，基本上是每一页的图像。如果你需要的话，就像挤压在一起。如果你喜欢的话，有 PostScript
into that. So it has support for many different formats. It's pretty awesome. So this is pretty flexible and it kind of is right up our alley as programmers. This is similar to writing HTML and CSS. Yeah, totally. So you kind of write your markup for what you want to type, and you don't worry about all this other stuff.
。所以它支持许多不同的格式。这太棒了。所以这非常灵活，作为程序员，这正合我们的胃口。这类似于编写 HTML 和 CSS。是的，完全正确。所以你有点像为你想要输入的内容编写标记，而不必担心所有这些其他事情。
Yeah, exactly. And then you can kind of worry about formatting as a separate process. Yeah, that's a perfect analogy. It's just like that. And then that way, later on, if you decide, oh, I totally want to change the look and feel of my website, but I don't want to have to, like, redo all the HTML and JavaScript. Well, you just change your CSS file. So this is the same kind of thing. Like, you can actually have a paper that you submit to one conference or that you put on, you know, your website.
是的，完全正确。然后你可以把格式化作为一个单独的过程来担心。是的，这是一个完美的类比。就像那样。然后这样，以后，如果你决定，哦，我完全想改变我网站的外观和感觉，但我不想不得不，就像，重做所有的 HTML 和 JavaScript。嗯，你只需要更改你的 CSS 文件。所以这是同样的事情。就像，你实际上可以有一篇提交给一个会议的论文，或者你放在，你知道，你的网站上的论文。
And if somebody else likes your paper, you can you can you know give it to them and they shim out content and then they can you know put their own style on it so yeah this is pretty flexible it's something that you know it's good to be aware of because it does it's useful it it's kind of one of those like as a programming topic it's not like is it a dynamically typed language yeah that's right i mean we're not getting into those kind of it is turn complete oh okay i'm sure that's not pretty code to look at. You know, maybe we'll have to get back into some where we're talking about a lot of those kind of deep topics.
如果别人喜欢你的论文，你可以，你可以，你知道，把它给他们，然后他们去掉内容，然后他们可以，你知道，把他们自己的风格放在上面，所以是的，这非常灵活，这是你知道的，值得注意的事情，因为它确实很有用，它有点像作为编程主题，它不像它是一种动态类型语言，是的，没错，我的意思是，我们没有进入那种，它是图灵完备的，哦，好的，我肯定那不是好看的代码。你知道，也许我们得回到一些我们正在谈论很多那种深层话题的地方。
But this is something that's definitely helpful because people writing resumes, people writing any sort of, you know, to practice with this and to kind of learn it and understand that it's out there. If you see it on somewhere, you'll know what it means. Yep. I think the biggest use case is going to be resumes.
但这绝对是有帮助的，因为人们写简历，人们写任何种类的，你知道，练习这个并学习它并理解它存在。如果你在某处看到它，你就会知道它是什么意思。是的。我认为最大的用例将是简历。
So, I mean, other than people who have to write, you know, conference papers and things for school. But, you know, if you're going to do your resume, I highly recommend that you use LaTeX. And we'll show you, we'll talk about a little later some tools which will make it easy. Actually, later is now. Okay, later is now?
所以，我的意思是，除了那些必须写，你知道，会议论文和学校作业的人之外。但是，你知道，如果你要写简历，我强烈建议你使用 LaTeX。我们稍后会向你展示，我们会谈论一些工具，这些工具会让它变得容易。实际上，稍后就是现在。好的，稍后就是现在？
All right. Some tools that make this easy when you're ready to write in the tech. Yeah. So I use Lix, which is it sounds dirtier than it is. Wait, it didn't sound dirty. Lix? It didn't sound dirty. Now it does.
好的。当你准备好用 TeX 编写时，一些让这变得容易的工具。是的。所以我使用 LyX，听起来比实际情况更脏。等等，它听起来不脏。LyX？它听起来不脏。现在听起来脏了。
Now I gave everyone the mental image. Okay. So Lix, L-Y-Xx you dirty people out there licks is a whizzy wig editor that supports latex where are these exports to latex no this is whizzy wig oh so this is a cool thing so licks looks and feels like microsoft uh word but then it exports to tech, which is pretty awesome. And, you know, of course, they did the thing where you can give it an installation of LaTeX, and it'll do the whole thing.
现在我给了每个人心理图像。好的。所以 LyX，L-Y-X，你们这些肮脏的人，LyX 是一个支持 LaTeX 的所见即所得编辑器，这些导出到 LaTeX，不，这是所见即所得，哦，所以这是一个很酷的事情，所以 LyX 看起来和感觉就像 Microsoft Word，但它导出到 TeX，这非常棒。而且，你知道，当然，他们做了你可以给它一个 LaTeX 安装的事情，它会做整个事情。
Like, it'll go straight to PDF, HTML, all these things. But so LaTeX also kind of wraps up this idea, like these algorithms for actually doing, like, justification and what should go into the new line and how stuff should be rendered, that kind of rendering rendering it is not only just the language and the style but also this rendering yeah to kind of so call it an image right like pdf or this dvi like as an image right like how how many letters should be on each line what should the font look like i mean it handles that as well yeah totally and it handles the placement of images you know on the page right
比如，它会直接转到 PDF，HTML，所有这些东西。但所以 LaTeX 也某种程度上总结了这个想法，比如这些用于实际执行的算法，比如对齐，什么应该进入新行，以及东西应该如何渲染，那种渲染，渲染它不仅仅是语言和样式，还有这种渲染，是的，为了某种程度上，所以称之为图像，对吧，比如 PDF 或这个 DVI，就像一个图像，对吧，比如每一行应该有多少个字母，字体应该看起来像什么，我的意思是，它也处理那个，是的，完全正确，而且它处理图像的放置，你知道，在页面上，对吧
right you'll know to like move an image to the next page and all that stuff. So it's even more clever than that. It will actually, if you have one line by itself on a page, it'll move it to the next page. So you don't have what's called an orphan line on a page. So it does all these really clever things that if you're doing it in Word, you'd have to manually do it, like hit enter a few times. It just does that for you. Just pretty clever. So yeah, you could write your
对，你会知道，比如把一张图片移到下一页等等。所以它甚至比那更聪明。它实际上会，如果你在页面上有一行，它会把它移到下一页。所以你不会有页面上所谓的孤行。所以它做了所有这些非常聪明的事情，如果你在 Word 中做，你必须手动做，比如按几次回车键。它只是为你做那个。相当聪明。所以是的，你可以写你的
resume in Lix using like the Lix, you know, WYSIWYG editor and get it to look kind of how you want. And then you just with a couple of clicks, it goes to HTML and it goes to PDF. And, you know, you could do this in Word, like Word actually exports to HTML. But the HTML that Word generates is complete garbage. And it's because Word doesn't have this decoupled, you know? Like, when you export LaTeX to HTML, you have your source code, which it creates, like, an HTML file for. And then you have your style that turns into a CSS file. Like, it naturally flows from one to the other. If you've ever exported from Word to HTML, it is just the most
简历在 LyX 中使用像 LyX，你知道，所见即所得编辑器，并让它看起来像你想要的那样。然后你只需要点击几下，它就变成了 HTML，它就变成了 PDF。而且，你知道，你可以在 Word 中做这个，比如 Word 实际上导出到 HTML。但 Word 生成的 HTML 完全是垃圾。这是因为 Word 没有这种解耦，你知道吗？比如，当你把 LaTeX 导出到 HTML 时，你有你的源代码，它为它创建了一个 HTML 文件。然后你有你的样式，它变成了 CSS 文件。就像，它自然地从一个流向另一个。如果你曾经从 Word 导出到 HTML，那简直就是你一生中见过的最
god-awful thing you've ever seen in your life. You can tell the machine generated is just complete garbage. Do your resume in Lix and you'll be well rewarded. You'll be able to put your resume on your website and it'll look awesome. I assume it's also able to do the whole
糟糕的东西。你可以看出机器生成的东西完全是垃圾。用 LyX 做你的简历，你会得到很好的回报。你将能够把你的简历放在你的网站上，它看起来会很棒。我假设它也能够做整个
view source and then edit your tech file directly. So if you can't figure out what button combination to push to make this thing do this. Yeah, so it's a little bit trickier than that. What you can do is you can do view source and I'll show you what it looks like. But if you want to manually put in tech code, you have to actually go to insert and say insert tech code. So you can manually put in tech code you have to do like you have to actually go to insert and say insert like
查看源代码，然后直接编辑你的 TeX 文件。所以如果你弄不清楚要按什么按钮组合来让这个东西做这个。是的，所以这比那稍微棘手一点。你可以做的是你可以查看源代码，我会向你展示它看起来是什么样子。但如果你想手动输入 TeX 代码，你必须实际去插入并说插入 TeX 代码。所以你可以手动输入 TeX 代码，你必须做，比如你必须实际去插入并说插入
tech code so you can manually put tech code but um but uh um it'll actually let you do anything tech will do and it'll actually when you're creating functions and things like that like mathematical functions it'll let you write tech code oh okay so yeah it's pretty pretty freaking cool um so i have not used this a lot so i will not have any tools yeah for tools i mean like i said licks is a great tool if you're going to write latex um definitely use licks it makes your life a lot easier um we talked a little bit about the uses of latex you know mainly academic writing people people writing books, textbooks. Any reference material that you read will probably be generated in Vitae. I'm intrigued by this bibliography generation thing.
TeX 代码，所以你可以手动输入 TeX 代码，但是嗯，但是嗯，它实际上会让你做任何 TeX 会做的事情，而且它实际上会在你创建函数和类似的东西时，比如数学函数，它会让你写 TeX 代码，哦，好的，所以是的，它非常非常酷，嗯，所以我没有用过这个很多，所以我不会有任何工具，是的，对于工具，我的意思是，就像我说的，LyX 是一个很好的工具，如果你要写 LaTeX，绝对使用 LyX，它让你的生活容易得多，嗯，我们谈论了一点关于 LaTeX 的用途，你知道，主要是学术写作，人们写书，教科书。你阅读的任何参考资料都可能是用 Vitae 生成的。我对这个参考文献生成的东西很感兴趣。
This seems like a good idea. Yeah. I hate making bibliographies. Yeah, that's a nightmare, right? So, yeah, clearly resume. And we found this out today. You know, someone often says, oh, look at my CV. Well, CV is curriculum vitae which i we knew that we
这看起来是个好主意。是的。我讨厌制作参考文献。是的，那是噩梦，对吧？所以，是的，显然是简历。我们今天发现了这一点。你知道，有人经常说，哦，看看我的 CV。嗯，CV 是 curriculum vitae，我们知道那个
knew that much but if you have two cvs that is actually curricula vitae that's right not curriculum vitae yeah vitaes or you're you're making plural the wrong word yeah yeah in latin you pluralize the the first word or maybe vitae is an adjective or something i don't know that's like life story right so like curriculum is like the the noun part and vitae is the adjective part oh we're nerding out now yeah so you don't say i i uh i have three reds dog three red have three red dogs. But just like in many languages, the adjective follows the noun. And so then, I don't know Latin.
我们知道那么多，但如果你有两个 CV，那实际上是 curricula vitae，没错，不是 curriculum vitae，是的，vitaes，或者你把错误的词复数化了，是的，是的，在拉丁语中，你复数化第一个词，或者也许 vitae 是形容词之类的，我不知道，那就像生活故事，对吧，所以 curriculum 就像名词部分，vitae 是形容词部分，哦，我们现在在书呆子气，是的，所以你不要说我，我，我有三个红狗，三个红，有三个红狗。但就像在许多语言中一样，形容词跟在名词后面。所以然后，我不知道拉丁语。
That's what Wikipedia said. I think it makes more sense that the adjective should follow the noun. It does in a way because you know what you're talking about. Yeah, you should know that it's the dog. Bad English. That's red and fluffy and furry. You should write a letter. Yeah, otherwise you get the wrong thing in your head.
那是维基百科上说的。我认为形容词应该跟在名词后面更有意义。它在某种程度上确实如此，因为你知道你在谈论什么。是的，你应该知道那是狗。糟糕的英语。那是红色的，毛茸茸的。你应该写一封信。是的，否则你的脑子里会得到错误的东西。
Yeah, letter to the English editor. I don't know who that is, but you write it. Actually, you should email the president of the internet. Oh. And then the president of the internet could help you find who the president of English is. There you go. There you go. Totally.
是的，给英语编辑的信。我不知道那是谁，但你写它。实际上，你应该给互联网总裁发电子邮件。哦。然后互联网总裁可以帮你找到英语总裁是谁。给你。给你。完全正确。
Maybe I'll email the inventor of the internet because that's the person who I know. Al Gore, right? You know Al Gore? No, but I know that he invented the internet. Oh, you just know his name okay so we're gonna start there okay uh I think we're definitely out of time now okay so uh any parting words no uh check out check out our book recommendations yeah we uh this is our first book recommendation so we purposely chose one that we believe strongly is a good book so we chose two I like that you, so we purposely chose one that we believe strongly is a good book. We chose two. I like that you chose one.
也许我会给互联网发明者发电子邮件，因为那是我认识的人。Al Gore，对吧？你认识 Al Gore？不，但我知道他发明了互联网。哦，你只是知道他的名字，好的，所以我们要从那里开始，好的，嗯，我想我们现在绝对没时间了，好的，嗯，有什么临别赠言吗，不，嗯，看看我们的书推荐，是的，我们，这是我们的第一本书推荐，所以我们特意选择了一本我们坚信是好书的书，所以我们选择了两本，我喜欢你，所以我们特意选择了一本我们坚信是好书的书。我们选择了两本。我喜欢你选择了一本。
We each chose one. Oh, okay. That's what I meant. So we chose one book that really mattered, and then we chose Head vs. Dime Pattern. Oh! People are going to get the wrong idea, man. Both of these books are amazing.
我们每个人都选择了一本。哦，好的。这就是我的意思。所以我们选择了一本真正重要的书，然后我们选择了《Head First 设计模式》。哦！人们会产生错误的印象，伙计。这两本书都很棒。
And so, yeah, thanks for listening to the show. Thanks for, you know, we complained about it using a terabyte of bandwidth last month, but it's amazing. It's great that we have that many people listening to the show. Keep listening. Yeah. And we won't turn this into an advertisement palooza. Oh, no, it won't be like that at all.
所以，是的，感谢收听节目。感谢，你知道，我们抱怨它上个月使用了 1 TB 的带宽，但这太棒了。有那么多人收听节目真是太好了。继续收听。是的。而且我们不会把它变成广告狂欢。哦，不，根本不会那样。
Like I said, we generally believe in these books. And the other thing is the next show we're going to do is definitely going to be a real programming topic that i know a lot of people will be interested in so okay we've done the mailbag now we did latex so you kind of hardcore we want hardcore programming yeah show off next time for us to show off our programming chops next time we're going to we're going to show some pretty awesome stuff all right well till next time all right see you guys later the intro music is axo by biner pilot programming throwdown is distributed under a creative commons attribution share alike 2.0 license you're free to share copy distribute transmit the work to remix adapt the work but you must provide attribution to patrick and i
就像我说的，我们通常相信这些书。另一件事是下一期节目我们要做的一定是一个真正的编程主题，我知道很多人会感兴趣，所以好的，我们现在做了邮件袋，我们做了 LaTeX，所以你有点硬核，我们想要硬核编程，是的，下次炫耀一下，让我们下次炫耀我们的编程技巧，我们要展示一些非常棒的东西，好的，好吧，直到下次，好的，回头见，伙计们，片头音乐是 Biner Pilot 的 Axo，Programming Throwdown 在知识共享署名-相同方式共享 2.0 许可下分发，你可以自由分享、复制、分发、传输作品，以重新混合、改编作品，但你必须提供对 Patrick 和我的署名
and share alike in kind There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
并以相同方式共享。这一集还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子来发表评论。